wir sind wie immer vor ort und von hier
aus begrüßen wir sie sehr herzlich aus
düsseldorf zu einem bestimmt spannenden
wahlabend die landtagswahl in nordrhein
westfalen gilt wegen der großen zahl der
wahlberechtigten traditionell als kleine
bundestagswahl
und in der tat hatten wahlen in
nordrhein westfalen häufig auch
auswirkungen auf den bund acht monate
nachdem spd erfolg bei der
bundestagswahl und eine woche nach einem
grandiosen cdu sieg in schleswig
holstein ist hier nun die frage wer
macht das rennen cdu oder spd während
nordrhein westfalen künftig regieren
wird ist matthias tatsächlich auf diese
wahl hat es auf jeden fall in sich wir
haben es gehört 13 millionen
wahlberechtigte nordrhein westfalen das
hat schon testcharakter längst vorbei
sind die zeiten als die spd hier
unangefochtener platzhirsch war
sozialdemokratisches stammland das war
einmal jetzt sehen wir wie schon vor
fünf jahren ein knappes rennen der
beiden volksparteien um platz eins noch
regiert schwarz-gelb aber dafür wird es
wohl nicht mehr reichen selbst wenn die
cdu in unserer letzten umfrage am ende
die nase vorn hat die regierungsbildung
wird kein selbstläufer denn die grünen
könnten königsmacher sein und neben
schwarz grün auch rot grün oder die
ampel inthronisieren diese entscheidung
wird so oder so ein starkes signal nach
berlin senden so ist es die
forschungsgruppe wahlen hat zuletzt
einen vorsprung für die cdu vor der spd
gemessen wir werden sehen ob sich das in
der prognose die immer pünktlich um 18
uhr auch bestätigt in schleswig-holstein
letzte woche haben wir gesehen dass der
krieg in der ukraine ein thema war vor
allem die auswirkungen die energie und
preise wie ist das hier in nrw matthias
kubitza mit einem überblick über themen
und sorgen die die reederinnen und
wählern hier beschäftigen
weltlage und landespolitik geben hier
die richtung vor für kreuze setzen
schauen wir genauer auf die themen die
das bevölkerungsreichste bundesland
bewegen von der millionenstadt mit dem
bis ins bodenständige münsterland
nordrhein westfalen das sind krasse
kontraste
nrw ist nach wie vor so etwas wie der
maschinenraum der republik immer offen
für neues und wandel doch angesichts von
krieg und krise fällt auch hier zur zeit
der optimismus schwer im moment läuft
alles ziemlich schief es gibt hier nur
den krieg ich ne
war jeder spricht davon da sollte man
erst mal gucken dass man das know how
reihe kriegt man merkt aber vom gefühl
her dass alles um meiner und eurer wird
man ständig geld ausgibt im schatten der
krise ungelöste probleme ruhrpott
realität armut und zuwanderung kaum
chancen dafür viel frust der
strukturwandel an vielen stellen
gescheitert
gibt der schäbige gegen illegale bochum
dortmund gelsenkirchen es gibt auch sehr
schöne
gelsenkirchen war eine vorzeigestadt und
heute ist sie so richtig verkommenheit
stadt gelsenkirchen die city so arm
geworden kann man jetzt sagen in ruhe
kurz und knapp ja die politik hat 30
jahre verbannt auch die verkehrswende
für das 18 millionen einwohner land eine
riesen mission vorzeige fahrradstadt
münster macht es vor die meisten anderen
kommen nicht hinter staus und
überlastete strecken vor allem an rhein
und ruhr auch die häufig oft nicht
pünktlich in berlin benutze ich sie
häufiger ja weil ich finde da kommt
immer was in paris kommt auch immer was
in köln kommt nix oder mit verspätung
auf ihr fahrrad eigentlich nur
schrecklich schrecklich gestern war ich
in holland bin da gefahren wunderschön
man kann fahren aber hier das ist so ein
desaster
komplizierte baustellen also in
nordrhein westfalen zum glück geht es
jetzt ohne stau zurück ins wahlstudio
so ist es die zdf studioleiterin in
nordrhein westfalen ist dort vorbei die
den wahlkampf genau beobachtet hat und
dort wir erinnern uns noch mal kurz vor
fünf jahren da war es auch knapp und am
ende machte der cdu herausforderer armin
laschet war das damals das rennen mit
einer starken fdp schaffte den
regierungswechsel was lag denn jetzt so
im wahlkampf in der luft wieder ein
wechsel nee das ist eher ein kopf an
kopf rennen das sich die beiden großen
parteien cdu und spd seit monaten
liefern mit leichten vorteilen für die
cdu in den letzten zeit jetzt in den
letzten tagen aber das gilt auch für die
personen hendrik wüst hat das amt des
ministerpräsidenten gerade mal vor
sieben monaten von armin laschet
übernommen das hat nicht gereicht um
einen amtsbonus aufzubauen er hat alles
versucht um bekannt und beliebt zu
werden ersteres ist ihm gelungen da ist
ihm auch das glück ein wenig holz
gewesen als vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
da konnte er öffentlich wirken aber so
richtig populär ist im land noch nicht
und das gleiche gilt für den
herausforderer thomas kutschaty von der
spd der war 27 jahre lang justizminister
im kabinett von h ihre kraft aber
bekannt ist er nicht im land das hat
sich jetzt im laufe der kampagne ein
bisschen geändert aber wenn man so fragt
wer liegt da vorne da sind die beiden
immer noch recht nah in den
persönlichkeits werten ja das ist am
ende die frage wer hat eine
regierungsmehrheit wer hat da genug
optionen
die fdp ist ja in den forum fragen
schwächer deshalb könnte es eben für
schwarz gelb eine fortsetzung hier nicht
reichen beim letzten mal waren die
ungeheuer stark und jetzt ist das bild
bei den grünen eigentlich anders die
waren letzte mal so schwach und werden
jetzt stark bewertet genau die grünen
die haben es erst mal leicht dirigieren
nicht mit und die profitieren auch von
der prominenz ihrer polit stars im bund
von annalena baerbock und robert habeck
umgekehrt ist das bei der fdp die hat
nämlich probleme mit der schulpolitik im
land dirigiert mit das schul ressort ist
in liberaler hand und er herrscht sehr
viel unzufriedenheit interessant ist
dass es bei der vergangenen wahl 2017
genau umgekehrt war da hatten die grünen
das schulressort das hat auch gehörig
dazu beigetragen dass die grünen so
schlecht abgeschnitten haben es könnte
also diesmal ähnlich sein und noch ein
wort zur afd die liegen in den umfragen
so bei 7 prozent eine zerstrittene
partei aber sie haben chancen in den
landtag wieder einzuziehen wir werden
sehen danke für den moment dörte verband
ja wenn es klappt ist dann mobilisiert
das in der regel die wähler das gefühl
es geht um was man isst stimme
entscheidet bringt die menschen an die
wahlurne jedenfalls wenn nicht so tolles
ausflugswetter ist wie heute linda
kirchen ist heute wieder als wähler
reporterin unterwegs und hat am
nachmittag hier in düsseldorf die
stimmung im wahlvolk schon mal
ausgelotet
wahltag in nrw und gefühlt ist ganz
düsseldorf unterwegs kein wunder bei
diesem schönen wetter morgen sollte
allerdings vielleicht regen wechselhafte
aussichten gilt das auch für die politik
das fragen wir wählerinnen und wähler
und bei mir sind jetzt christopher und
samira familia bei wahl in nrw nach
wahlen da bleibt ja selten alles beim
alten wie ist dein eindruck heute von
diesem wahlsonntag ich hoffe dass nicht
alles beim alten bleibt das ja warum ja
weil ich hoffe dass ich was es hat das
ist mein wunsch auf jeden fall in
umfragen was jetzt zuletzt der knapp
zwischen cdu und spd
der wird heute abend die nase vorn haben
ich hoffe die spd wenn ich ehrlich wenn
aber ich lasse mich überraschen ist ja
wirklich sehr knapp bis jetzt gewesen
und was sind so die themen die ganz
dringend nach dieser wahl angegangen
werden müssen in nrw insgesamt also ich
finde verkehrswende auf jeden fall
wichtiges thema und natürlich auch thema
unter den klimaschutz definitiv vielen
dank euch noch einen schönen tag das
waren zwei stimmen von insgesamt 13
millionen wahlberechtigten und damit
zurück ins studio stimmen aus dem
sommerlichen düsseldorf hier im
wahlstudio ist es auch schön kuschelig
so und wir fragen jetzt mal
repräsentativ nach der stimmung meint
ihr als was sagen denn die form fragen
welche regierung wünschen sie hier die
nordrhein westfalen gibt er eine
wechselstimmung oder ein weiters mal bis
jetzt hat ja in düsseldorf schwarz gelb
regiert mit der denkbar knappen mehrheit
von nur einen sitz und dafür wird es
wohl nicht mehr reichen wir schauen mal
was die wahlberechtigten sich sonst
wünschen da steht ganz oben rot grün ob
es dafür aber rechnerisch reichen wird
ist völlig unklar in der beliebtheit als
nächstes cdu und grüne aber auch spd
grüne und fdp liegen relativ dicht
beieinander die grünen könnten in
nordrhein- westfalen die richtung
bestimmen was wollen die anhänger der
grünen das schauen wir uns hier mal an
ein rot grünes bündnis das fänden 79
prozent der grünen-anhänger gut
schwarz-grün nur 55 prozent und die
ampel aus spd grünen und fdp 49 prozent
dankeschön matthias für diesen ausblick
und bei uns ist wie immer professor karl
rudolf korte den wahlen mit uns
begleitet grund die
nordrhein-westfälischen verhältnisse
besonders gut kennt als professor an der
universität duisburg essen professor
karte schwer vorherzusagen wer am ende
hier düsseldorf regieren wird aber wie
haben sie die stimmung wahrgenommen in
den letzten wochen ja ich finde
teilnehmende beobachtung für mich in der
tat diesmal aber das ist ein politisches
erdbeben was man spürt was immer von
dieser republik auf alles ausgerichtet
worden ist wie ein donnerschlag ist ein
schlüsselland für politischen parteien
wettbewerb und auch ein entscheidungs
land auch vor allen dingen vor dem
hintergrund der transformation streamen
die dann steht also berlin war nie
unbeeindruckt von düsseldorf das wird
auch heute so sein das ist in der tat
war 2005 war danach wurde eine
bundestagswahl ausgerufen ich erinnere
mich gut 2017 gewannen auch die cdu in
diesem land was ja immer als herzkammer
der sozialdemokratie
bezeichnet wird gilt die gleichung
eigentlich noch nein und davor war er
auch die union sehr stark hat viele
jahre hier regiert seit 2005 ist es
eigentlich ein swing state also mit
unterschiedlichen wählerwanderungen und
insofern sind hier eher orientierungslos
aden unterwegs die immer etwas anderes
wählen offenbar das macht wähler stark
weil sie natürlich unterschiede
akzentuieren können und macht parteien
eher schwach weil sie doch nicht sicher
sein können souverän gewählt zu werden
und in der tat zeichnet sich auch hier
schon ab das ist ein regierungswechsel
geben wird der für schwarz gelb wird es
aller wahrscheinlichkeit aufgrund der
schwäche der fdp nicht mehr reichen
vielen dank für den moment größer korte
und wir nähern uns jetzt genauer mal dem
politischen personal matthias kugel kam
mit dem blick auf die
spitzenkandidatinnen der parteien und
ihre herausforderung
kann kutschaty wüst überholen und wie
weit kommen die anderen der wahlkampf
vor allem das duell spannend bis auf die
letzten meter
thomas kutschaty der rother aus dem
ruhrgebiet fordert ihn heraus hendrik
wüst den konservativen ministerin
der 45-jährige wüst erst vor einem
halben jahr das düsseldorfer spitzenamt
von armin laschet war vorher
nrw-verkehrsminister er gibt sich als
moderner landesvater sein amtsbonus aber
bisher geringen wüst cdu nur knapp vor
der spd
also ich das amt des ministerpräsidenten
übernommen habe hat meine partei 13
prozentpunkte hinter der spd gelegen
heute legen wir in den aktuellen
umfragen mindestens 2 prozent vorne also
die richtung stimmt herausforderer
kutschaty erzählt gern seine aufstieg
story als sohn eines eisenbahners aus
essen noch unter hannelore kraft feier
auch schon mal minister
nun also seit an seit mit kanzler scholz
und chance auf sieg für die spd anders
als in kiel kiel ist nicht köln und
wusste es nicht günther das sind die
entscheidenden unterschiede zwischen
schleswig holstein und nordrhein
westfalen hier nordrhein westfalen
wollen die menschen einen wechsel die
grünen stärker als vor fünf jahren
könnten mit wüst koalieren vielleicht
aber auch mit fertigen es ist am ende
fast unentscheiden tweer in der
staatskanzlei einzieht welcher mann wir
wollen so stark werden wie noch nie bei
einer landtagswahl hier in nordrhein
westfalen für schwarz-gelb wird es wohl
nicht mehr reichen die fdp offen für ein
dreierbündnis unter coach ati- oder
für uns ist es wichtig dass es keine
koalition gibt wo die grüne alleine mit
einem partner unterwegs und ich glaube
dass wir fürs land mich gut die afg ohne
machtoption wohl weiter im landtag sieht
sich selbst
[Musik]
klare oppositionspartei
die sich auch gegen diese diese konnten
sind es demokratie stellt die wir auch
im landtag immer wieder erleben die
nrw-wahl kunstform zieht prognose und
hochrechnungen und versprechen einen
spannenden abend im wald studie
unsere reporterinnen und reporter sind
auch an diesem wahlabend natürlich
unterwegs um die stimmung bei den
parteien einzufangen und für beginnen
mal den reigen mit den kleineren
parteien aus dem stand auf 7 4 prozent
kam die afg vor fünf jahren und zog
damit in den landtag ein ein wichtiger
schritt hin zu dem ziel auch im westen
fuß zu fassen und zu wachsen aber danach
wieder böhmer sieht es fünf jahre später
nicht aus letzte woche in schleswig
holstein die afg rausgeflogen was
erwartet man hier
ja ich würde sagen vorsichtiger
optimismus ist hier angesagt sie hatten
7,4 prozent und die markt und fragen
verorten sie bei sie prozent und darauf
hoffen sie ja auch wieder dass sich das
einfahren quirin streitereien
zerwürfnisse auch dass projekte die
arbeiter auf die in den letzten monaten
sie hatte in den neun jahren und ihre
existenz hier nordrhein westfalen 9
vorsitzende und der neue ein junger
36-jähriger mann seit februar im amt der
soll jetzt hier die gräben ein bisschen
kicken im landtag sind sie aufgefallen
vor allen dingen durch eine flut an
kleinen anfragen und sie sind einsamer
spitzenreiter was ordnungsrufe und rügen
angeht kann andere fraktionen wollte mit
ihnen zusammenarbeiten
und sollten sie reinkommen dürfte sich
daran auch nichts ändern
peter vielen dank weiter zur fdp die
vorher vor fünf jahren ihr bestes
ergebnis in der nrw geschichte ein und
sicherte armin laschet die
regierungsmehrheit
schwarz-gelb laschet und lindner nun ist
laschet geschichte und christian lindner
regiert in berlin mit rot-grün kassen
ruhiger die fdp muss sich auf starke
verluste einstellen und plötzlich darum
kämpfen überhaupt die fünf prozent hürde
zu schaffen worauf stellen sich die
liberalen
damit hinter den liberalen feiern hier
im foyer des salons mitnehmen modernen
medienhafen düsseldorf
der caterer das befähigung von einem
szenelokal das den schönen slogan hat
hier wird der genuss gefeiert und das
feiern wird genossen ob man das für die
liberalen heute abend sagen kann ein
großes fragezeichen
2017 daten an das spitzenergebnis
eingefahren 12,6 prozent aber die
umfragen sehen die liberalen jetzt bei
nur gerade mal vielleicht sechs prozent
und die der spitzenkandidat joachim
stamm der vize-ministerpräsident hat
anfang april noch die parole ausgegeben
wir wollen zweistellig werden wir wollen
mit schwarz gelb weiter regieren aber
das sagen wir hier einige liberale
hinter vorgehaltener hand er ist halt
nicht das zugpferd wie christian lindner
und die liberalen müssen wirklich
zittern ob sie überhaupt für irgendetwas
gebraucht werden eine jamaika koalition
oder eine mögliche ampel das ist völlig
offen also keine party champagnerlaune
hier der champagner ist nicht einmal
kalt gestellt ich habe an der bar
gefragt denn der wurde gar nicht von der
liberalen bestellt carsten also wir
hören zitterpartie bei der fdp und
weiter zu den grünen vor fünf jahren
waren die sehr schwach 6,4 prozent
kleinste fraktion im landtag und ab in
die opposition heute abend ina baltes
könnten die grünen die größten gewinner
werden wie es die erwartung ja hier
fühlt es sich bei den grünen und die
erwartung ist hoch um nicht zu sagen
sehr hoch die grünen haben zwei große
ziele ausgegeben zum anfang dieser
landtagswahl sie wollten in die
regierungsbeteiligung und sie wollten
das beste landtagswahlergebnis
jemals einfahren und das war 2010 12
prozent und jetzt liegen sie in den
umfragen stabil bei 15 16 sogar mehr
prozent daher sind die erwartungen
natürlich sehr hoch und wir stehen hier
zufall oder nicht an der staatskanzlei
von nordrhein westfalen hier sind die
ministerpräsidenten und es ist sehr
wahrscheinlich dass monat neubauer die
nächste
stellvertretende ministerpräsidentin von
nordrhein-westfalen wird sie hatten sich
betroffen nach in allen politischen
richtungen gezeigt sie hat sich flexibel
gezeigt und wenig ich sag's mal
dogmatisch grün und ich lege mich jetzt
mal fest das wird hier heute die
wahlparty der wahlpartys sein die grünen
sind sehr siegessicher und sie wissen
dass wahrscheinlich an ihnen kein weg
einer regierungsbildung vorbeigeht
dankeschön immer so weit der blick auf
die derzeit kleineren parteien bleiben
cdu und spd titelverteidiger und
herausforderer und das rennen ist
vergleichsweise ausgeglichen nach den
formen fragen bei vorsprung für die cdu
nur knapp sieben monate hatte
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst hat sich
im amt bekannt zu machen das ist nicht
allzu viel um sich einen riesengroßen
amtsbonus zu erarbeiten matthias ja das
stimmt aber für einen vorsprung auf den
spd-herausforderer reicht es schon das
sehen wir in der nächsten grafik auf die
frage wen hätten sie lieber als
ministerpräsidenten
sagen 41 prozent lieber weiter mit
hendrik wüst einen wechsel zu thomas
kutschaty wünschen sich 33 prozent der
ist also durchaus noch in reichweite
schauen wir noch auf die bewertung von
politikerinnen und politikern aus land
und bund das ist hier die nächste grafik
eine skala von +5 sehr gut bis -5 sehr
schlecht da kommt hendrik wüst auf 1,8
cdu chef friedrich merz auf schwache 0,2
besser der olaf scholz 1,7 und noch
besser robert habeck 2,4 der auch
deutlich besser abschneidet als die
grüne spitzenkandidat sind hier im land
monat neubauer vor allem für die grünen
also gibt es rückenwind aus berlin ja
danke matthias und da sieht man schon
das ist auch ein spannendes rennen aus
bundespolitischer sicht deshalb schaut
berlin heute abend natürlich sehr
interessiert nach düsseldorf theo koll
tut das auch t um hallo wie sieht berlin
das als eine art stellvertreter wahl
geht es hier heute auch um scholz gegen
märz mit den grünen als königsmacher
absolut für die berliner politik ist es
eindeutig die wichtigste wahl des jahres
nordrhein westfalen hat ja immer etwas
von einer kleinen bundesrepublik bei 13
millionen wählern ist vieles auf den
bund übertragbar und anders als im
saarland oder in schleswig holstein gab
es ja diesmal keine alles
überstrahlenden personal waren auch
deshalb sagt die heutige wahl
wahrscheinlich viel aus über die lage
der parteien im bund der kanzler war
sehr präsent im wahlkampf gemeinsam für
nordrhein westfalen und deutschland
stand daher auf den großen plakatwänden
und damit wird das ergebnis auch mit ihm
und seiner bisherigen ampel politik nach
hause gehen bisher ist die
unzufriedenheit mit stolz in umfragen ja
größer als sie bei merkel jeweils aber
auch für die cdu und vor allem friedrich
merz steht viel auf dem spiel sollte in
der cdu der zweite junge
ministerpräsident bestätigt werden dann
rückt damit ein weiterer möglicher
konkurrent in die künftige
kanzlerkandidaten riga auf und für die
fdp dürfte das schwache das dritte
schwäche infolge auswirkungen auf ihr
künftiges verhalten in der ampel haben
denn sie hat zwar einige wichtige ampel
entscheidungen gewonnen aber verliert
offensichtlich die wähler und natürlich
die frage wie bildet sich der höhenflug
der grünen künftig ab in der
regierungskoalition also dieser abend
dürfte spuren hinterlassen so ist es
wohl dankeschön theo man sieht schon die
sehr interessante bundespolitische sicht
später dank bei theo koll die berliner
runde gegen 19 uhr 30 die das
wahlergebnis aufarbeiten wird da gibt es
ja dann auch genug themen haben wir
schon gesehen jetzt gucken wir auf die
uhr keine sechs minuten mehr bis zur
prognose die spannung steigt auch bei
den parteien wir schauen auf die
gemütslage weil cdu und spd und beginnen
bei den sozialdemokraten wo sich der
herausforderer thomas kutschaty sehr
gelassen gelassen gab in den letzten
tagen und gänzlich unbeeindruckt von dem
cdu sieg letzte woche in kelheim
schipanski dabei droht ja nicht weniger
als das schlechteste ergebnis für die
spd in nordrhein westfalen überhaupt in
welcher stimmung gehen die
sozialdemokraten in den abend
also ich sag mal die spd feiert in den
rheinterrassen wie man sieht ein
wirklich großer saal und die spd hat
auch großes vor und diese zuversicht
spiegelt sich auch in der weinauswahl
wieder der grauburgunder heißt
punktlandung und der rosé wunderschön
thomas kutschaty ist nicht sehr
zurückhaltend wenn es um machtoptionen
geht der hat sich den fraktionsvorsitz
geschnappt wenig später mit reichlich
ellenbogen auf den parteivorsitz klar
will er jetzt ministerpräsident werden
und auch gerne mit der spd als stärkste
partei aber hat auch immer klar gemacht
wenn das nicht gelingen sollte ist denn
nicht zögerlich trotzdem mit den grünen
oder der ampel eine koalition einzugehen
so kann es also sein dass er heute hier
zwar nicht gewinnt am ende aber trotzdem
als sieger vom platz geht und klar als
auch der abend klang und spannend werden
der eigentliche machtkampf aber beginnt
wohl erst morgen
möglich ist auch das dankeschön ball
fehlt noch der blick zur cdu armin
laschet war ohne doppelten boden in die
bundestagswahl gegangen als er
scheiterte war auch das
ministerpräsidenten-amt hier weg nun
soll hendrik wüst nicht nur den sieg
einfahren sondern natürlich auch das
regieren sichern wo schmiese bei der cdu
wie zuversichtlich ist die partei dass
beides klappt
naja sie gibt sich sehr zuversichtlich
sie will hier geschilderte garten party
machen wie immer hinter der
landeszentrale der cdu ist jetzt ja voll
geworden auch mit sehr viel prominenz
viele minister sind hier
landesministerin und minister und das
ist immer ein zeichen dafür dass man
zuversichtlich ist aber wenn man danach
fragt dann ist das bibbern doch da dass
es für rot-grün reichen könnte und dann
könnte der wahlgewinner am ende doch
nicht der sieger sein dann wäre es
vielleicht der ministerpräsident wies
der in die landesgeschichte eingänge mit
der kürzesten amtszeit als das ganze
wird man wissen in vier minuten die
monitore sind jetzt zugestellt mit
leuten spannend ist es mal gucken wie es
ausgeht und ob es heute abend schon
antwort gibt ja das ist in der tat
fraglich aber jetzt wollen wir uns erst
mal der prognose nähern damit man eine
neue grundlage hat um zu diskutieren und
in der tat ist es punktgenau in drei
minuten soweit die verbleibende zeit
können wir gut nutzen professor karte um
uns die ausgangslage noch mal ein
bisschen anzuschauen worauf kommt es an
in der tat lagen spd und cdu relativ
nahe beieinander wenn die spd nicht
vorne liegt kann sie trotzdem ja im
grunde noch hoffnungen haben auf eine
regierungsbildung jedenfalls auf eine
option das ist wie ein déjà vu zur
bundestagswahl dort lag die cdu mit
armin laschet an platz zwei und es hat
durchaus sein argument gegeben es zu
versuchen also eine mehrheit
hinzubekommen es ist legitim
es ist möglich nicht der wahlsieger der
juni also die größte fraktion im landtag
stellt muss automatisch
ministerpräsident werden und so könnte
es ja heute auch kommt insofern wird
nicht der wahlsieger heute am ende
ministerpräsident automatisch sondern
der sondierungs weltmeister aber es
kommt immer schon auch ein bisschen auf
den abstand allem wie groß der führende
dann wirklich vorn liegt das könnte
hendrik wüst in der tat seien als
cdu-ministerpräsidenten hier und für ihn
steht ja tatsächlich auch persönlich
viel auf dem spiel also entweder er wird
womöglich der neue hoffnungsträger der
cdu bis hin zum ganzen kandidaten oder
er bleibt eben episode jemand schrieb
winterkönig ja es wird eine kurze zeit
aber die nrw-cdu war ja auch im letzten
wahl ja sehr dominant die männer der cdu
haben das ganze war ja eigentlich
bestimmend insofern ist auch die frage
wie weit er je nachdem mit welchem
ergebnis auch weiterhin eine rolle
spielen wird trotzdem
die wahrnehmung ist natürlich schon dass
heute alles auf der kippe steht es geht
um den großen preis auch für ihn auf den
wird natürlich märz auch hoffen der cdu
bundesvorsitzende der aus nordrhein
westfalen kommt deshalb ist das für ihn
wichtig und herr scholz der
bundeskanzler muss natürlich auch darauf
setzen dass er so ein effekt produziert
für die spd das entscheidet sich ja auch
heute ja es ist unglaublich verwoben mit
bundespolitik nicht nur durch größe
sondern auch durch das personal mit märz
automatisch als in der wähler spielt es
eine große rolle und scholz war fast
mehr hier als woanders so fern ist ganz
klar dass die berliner republik heute
auch mit einem donnerschlag begleitet
wird 50 sekunden bis zur prognose ganz
kurz noch ein blick auf die fdp die ja
letzte woche in schleswig-holstein
verloren hat stark verloren und das
droht hier jetzt tatsächlich auch die
wird sie habe bestraft fürs regieren
offenbar opfer sie hatte ihre größe her
mit möllemann und mitglieder also mit
ganz starken personen die praktisch eine
fanmeile gebildet haben für die fdp und
das ist im moment nicht erkennbar und
die grünen sind natürlich hier absehbar
die großen gewinner darauf werden wir
jetzt schauen vielen dank professor
karte für den moment wir werden
sicherlich auch im laufe des wahlabends
viel zu besprechen haben und bereiten
uns jetzt das tun sie bitte auch
salzstangen weg stellen auf die prognose
vor denn die kommt in fünf sekunden 3 2
1 0 0 die cdu in nordrhein westfalen
landet bei 35 prozent mit gewinnen spd
28 das sind verluste die fdp 5,5 da sind
sehr deutliche verluste noch nicht ganz
sicher ob sie im landtag bleibt die afg
ebenso 55 leichte verluste auch hier
nicht ganz sicher ob es reicht die
grünen 18 prozent das ist plus 11,6 sehr
deutliche gewinne zweistellig linke 2,0
minus 2,9 mit verlusten nicht im landtag
und die anderen zusammen 6 prozent so da
ist die schere doch ziemlich deutlich
auseinander gegangen die cdu in front
was das nun für sitzverteilung und
mögliche koalition bedeutet das jetzt
von matthias von genau die
sitzverteilung im düsseldorfer landtag
dann schauen wir uns jetzt an wir gehen
von einer gesamtgröße von 199 sitzen
auch so war es bisher auch es kann aber
durch überhang und ausgleichsmandaten
sich noch verändern demnach käme die cdu
auf 76 sitze die spd auf 60 die fdp
werden sie denn drin ist auf zwölf die
afg mit der gleichen einschränkung auch
auf 12 und die grünen auf 39 sitze was
hieße das für die fähigkeit regierung zu
bilden hier in nordrhein westfalen hier
schauen wir nach der prognose die
derzeit amtierende regierung cdu und fdp
würde die absolute mehrheit die hier bei
dieser senkrechten linie liegt deutlich
verfehlen selbst dann wenn die fdp im
landtag ist was ja noch nicht klar ist
cdu und grüne schwarz grün kommt auf 115
das würde deutlich reichen spd und grüne
99 da fährt der zeit und wir haben beide
kleinparteien ja im landtag gesehen nur
einen sitz spd grüne und fdp auch das
würde relativ deutlich reichen wenn denn
die fdp drin ist ja also da sehen wir
rot grün würde im moment nicht gehen das
kann sich natürlich noch ändern jetzt
wollen wir mal zu den parteien schalten
und ich gehe sowohl schmiese bei der cdu
damit ja ich sehe es schon immer noch
gejubelt
bettina hier wurde jetzt schon heftig
wie bei einem gewonnenen fußballspiel
gesungen gegrölt nicht umarmt man hörte
förmlich die steine die den leuten von
dem herzen fallen weil man damit
gerechnet hat wenn es für rot grün
reicht dann könnte man könnte
rot grün geben
hier sehen wir den jubel
klar
die fdp und die schwarzen das wird
nichts mehr das war auch vorher klar
aber das glück hier ist nicht nur bei
den anhängern der cdu und den
mitgliedern dankeschön wulff beide cdu
das können wir jetzt schon mal kurz auch
mit einer bundespolitischen stimme
vertiefen nämlich mit karin prien die ja
seit januar stellvertretende
bundesvorsitzende ist der cdu ich
begrüße sie jetzt in berlin schönen
abend frau prien sie sind ja
cdu-bildungsministerin zugleich in
schleswig holstein auch wahlgewinnerin
der letzten woche nun fährt hier hendrik
wüst auch ein wahlsieg ein höher als
manche gedacht hatten was ist ja jetzt
aus ihrer sicht wert ist er damit durch
und auch weiterhin ministerpräsident es
hat zunächst mal ein großartiges
ergebnis für die cdu in nordrhein
westfalen und für hendrik wüst die cdu
ist klar stärkste kraft damit geht klar
ein regierungsauftrag für die cdu ein
her und lassen sie mich zunächst mal
hendrik wüst ganz persönlich gratulieren
dass sie einem wahnsinns aufholjagd die
er hingelegt hat aber auch den wal
kämpferinnen und wahlkämpfern in
nordrhein westfalen die irre gekämpft
haben und ein tolles ergebnis hingelegt
haben in der tat ist das so der
bundesvorsitzende friedrich merz der ja
selbst aus nordrhein westfalen stammt
hat sich hier im wahlkampf sehr ins zeug
gelegt was bedeutet jetzt dieser
wahlerfolg von hendrik wüst für ihn und
überhaupt für die bundes-cdu
lassen sich vielleicht zunächst auch
noch sagen dass ich auch den
mitbewerberinnen und mitbewerber von den
grünen ganz herzlich gratuliere auch die
sind zweifelsohne wahlsieger des
heutigen abends und jetzt heißt es
verantwortung zu übernehmen die cdu wird
das tun wird gespräche suchen um ein
zukunftsbündnis in nordrhein westfalen
auf den weg zu bringen und natürlich ist
das ein großer erfolg für die cdu im
bund für die cdu in den ländern wir
haben gemeinsam gewonnen wir sind
gemeinsam raus aus dem tal der tränen
insofern ist es ein guter tag für die
cdu deutschlands
aus dem tal der tränen gleichwohl muss
ja nun hendrik wüst erstmal die grünen
überzeugen an seiner seite in eine
regierung einzusteigen sie haben in
schleswig-holstein ja mit den grünen und
der fdp regiert was was muss wüst den
grünen bieten
es geht jetzt darum in einer für unser
land ja insgesamt herausfordernden
situationen dem viele
transformationsprozesse vorangebracht
werden müssen ein breites
gesellschaftliches bündnis zu schmieden
weit über die politischen lager hinweg
und da ist die cdu als stärkste kraft
gefordert verantwortung zu übernehmen
und mit den kolleginnen kollegen von den
grünen über ein solches zukunftsbündnis
zu verhandeln jetzt sehen wir eine
ziemliche schwäche der fdp 5,5 muss das
auch spreche jetzt auch mal die
bundespolitikerin an frau bremen muss
das auch der bundes-cdu sorgen machen
also zunächst mal ist das ein sicherlich
ein bisschen ungerecht gegenüber den
ministerinnen und ministern die dort in
in nordrhein westfalen eine gute arbeit
geleistet haben aber jahr für die fdp
sind natürlich nach heute abend auch
weitere fragen zu beantworten die aber
zunächst von der fdp beantwortet werden
müssen
dankeschön karim privater die
stellvertretende bundesvorsitzende der
cdu danke für diese schnellen ersten
reaktion und jetzt höre ich dass dort
aber auch eine stimme aus der fdp hat
dann können wir das schon vertiefen
bei mir ist jetzt alexander graf
lambsdorff von den liberalen
bundestagsabgeordneter hermsdorf ein so
schlechtes ergebnis für die liberalen
und das in folge in kiel war es ja auch
so schlecht worden ich glaube was wir
gesehen haben ist dass diese schwere
niederlage und die ist es ohne jeden
zweifel ähnlich wie in schleswig
holstein auch auf diesen effekt
zurückgeht dass ein unglaublich
personalisierte wahlkampf zwischen den
spitzenkandidaten geführt worden ist wir
haben gesehen der ministerpräsident hat
einen amtsbonus ich bin sicher manche
unserer anhängerinnen und anhänger sind
zu ihm gegangen das hat bei uns schwer
ins kontor bauen kurze antwort kann man
denn daraus überhaupt noch einen auftrag
zur regierungsbeteiligung in einer
dreier konstellation ableiten so früh am
abend wäre das einfach viel zu früh wir
werden das jetzt anschauen wir werden
mit den anderen parteien natürlich
irgendwann auch reden aber natürlich ist
das erst mal eine niederlage und für
viele von unseren abgeordneten kollegen
das ende ihrer parlamentarischen
laufbahn das bedauere ich
außerordentlich deswegen das ist im
moment noch nicht die zeit um über
solche fragen zu spekulieren herzlichen
dank und damit zurück ins studio ja und
der abend ist für die fdp in der tat
noch nicht zu ende denn es droht
tatsächlich dass sie auch noch aus dem
landtag heraus fallen könnte fünf
fünfeinhalb prozent das ist das ergebnis
der prognosen so jetzt gucken wir zur
spd augenhöhe gleich auf das hatte man
sich erhofft jetzt ist es doch deutlich
hinter der cdu war das wie war die
stimmung bei der prognose bei der spd
bettina ich sag mal 2 geteilt als man
den balken von der cdu sah na da war man
schon ein bisschen zähneknirschen dabei
und als man sagen dass der von der spd
noch mal niedriger ist als beim letzten
mal da wurde trotz sich geklatscht und
natürlich geht jetzt das rechnen los
reicht es für rot grün gibt es eine
machtoption mann ist sag ich mal
ambivalent heute abend unterwegs hinter
mir wird schon sekt getrunken hinter mir
wird schon kalkuliert was ich hier
auffallend finde ist momentan ist noch
kein prominentes gesicht von der spd
aufgetaucht man rechnet vielleicht auch
hinter den kulissen noch ein bisschen
nach und will noch sicher gehen was es
tatsächlich wird aber die ganz große
freude ist es noch nicht ich glaube man
kann schon sagen das hatte man sich
etwas besser vorgestreckt dankeschön
reist japans g für diese erste eindrücke
und das können wir vertiefen mit kevin
köhler hat spd generalsekretär der in
berlin ja zu uns gekommen ist um mich
hoffentlich hört ja keiner vor einer
woche haben wir schon über die krachende
niederlage für die spd in
schleswig-holstein gesprochen das ist
schon irgendwie nichts gutes ahnen jetzt
in der prognose 28 vielleicht nur knapp
28 damit können sie nicht zufrieden sein
oder
man kann sich immer mehr wünschen aber
wir sind dafür angetreten bei der
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen die
amtierende regierung ablösen zu können
ein wichtiges kriterium dafür ist
erfüllt schwarz gelb hat keine mehrheit
mehr die cdu hat am ende von der
zweitstimmen kampagne profitiert mit der
sie stimmen von der fdp abgezogen hat
aber die regierung die es abgewählt und
mit einer gewissen wahrscheinlichkeit
wird heute abend die möglichkeit haben
selbst eine neue landesregierung führen
zu können wahrscheinlich sogar eine
rot-grüne ausweislich aller umfragen das
bündnis was die menschen im land dort am
liebsten und das ist demokratie es wird
derjenige am ende gewählt im landtag zum
ministerpräsidenten
der eine mehrheit im parlament hinter
sich bekommt auf grundlage von
verhandlungen und um die wird es in den
nächsten tagen gehen wir uns heute mit
einer wahl zu tun die nicht bereits am
wahlabend alle fragen beantwortet die
wir uns zu stellen das stimmt wir haben
gerade gesehen rot-grün reichte
gleichwohl im moment nicht dazu müsste
noch eine partei rausfallen die fdp
womöglich
oder die afd dann könnte rot-grün
tatsächlich reichen aber wäre das dann
nicht im grunde eher ein rechter ein
rechenspiel als eine wirkliche
politische option
nein das sehe ich anders also erstens
hat die schwarz gelbe koalition damit
eine ein-stimmen-mehrheit die letzte
regiert also das ist sicherlich kein
argument und es muss auch nicht zwingend
eine andere partei aus dem landtag
heraus fallen sondern wir alle haben
erstmal zu warten wie sich die zahlen am
heutigen abend entwickeln im moment
liegen hochrechnung noch gar nicht vor
sondern nur erste prognosen
dementsprechend müssen wir gucken was
passiert beim letzten wahlabend vor fünf
jahren in nordrhein westfalen hat sich
der abstand von der spd zur cdu im laufe
des abends halbiert also glaube wir
sollten alle sehr vorsichtig mit
voreiligen kommentierungen sein wenn es
eine möglichkeit gibt eine regierung
unter führung der spd zu bilden und
werden wir selbstverständlich den
anderen parteien dafür gespräche
anbieten sind wir ja angetreten eine
solche regierung führen zu können wir
würden ja schindluder mit dem wal
auftrag den wir bekommen haben treibt
wenn wir die gelegenheit dann nicht
nutzten
selbst hier intensiv in nord-westfalen
wahlkampf gemacht das hat jetzt aber
nicht gereicht um thomas guth schade die
wirklich in führung zu bringen hätte der
kanzler effekt der scholz effekt nicht
stärker ausfallen müssen
das ist müßig zu diskutieren wir könnten
jetzt überlegen ob wir die prozente nie
dagewesen wären ohne die besucher von
olaf scholz aber bei unseren wahlkampf
veranstaltungen geht es um etwas anderes
sie sind auch lange genug dabei um zu
wissen glaubten in der spd da hat man
sich gegenseitig nicht im wahlkampf
besuchte wollte man wahlweise mit denen
in berlin oder mit denen im land nichts
zu tun haben wir entscheiden nicht mehr
nach umfragen tage in der spd ob wir
unsere genossinnen und genossen vor ort
unterstützen sondern ist für uns eine
selbstverständlichkeit diejenigen die
für die spd antreten vor ort und aktiv
zu unterstützen für uns alle in der
parteispitze und deswegen haben wir
richtig beherzt reingehängt und dieses
ergebnisses damit auch unser ergebnis
und wir sind nicht unzufrieden mit dem
ergebnis denn ich bleibe dabei es wird
uns heute abend davon bin ich fest
überzeugt die gelegenheit bieten ein
regierungswechsel für
nordrhein-westfalen herbeizuführen denen
sich menschen gewünscht haben
spd-generalsekretär um 18 uhr 11 wir
schauen einfach mal wie sich der abend
entwickelt vielen dank nach berlin und
jetzt schauen wir zu den grünen ja wir
haben es vorausgesehen die sind die
großen gewinner mit einem zweistelligen
plus und ich gebe zu jener bald ist ja
das war ein jubel um 18 uhr oder ja ich
sag es mal im twitter stil es war
gespannte erwartungen beim ergebnis von
cdu und spd war das schließlich der
künftige koalitionspartner sein wird
dann leichte berufe bei der fdp und
starke berufe bei der afg und dann
natürlich einen riesen jubel brach ihr
auch die ergebnisse kamen für die grünen
und monat neubauer ist dann ungewöhnlich
schnell hier sofort vor ihr wald folge
treten die grünen sind hier sehr
zahlreich versammelt ist ein sehr junger
landesverband sind sehr viele junge
leute hier die partei hat in den letzten
jahren ihre mitgliederzahl fast
verdoppelt auf
26.000 mitglieder und davon sind einige
zählen gekommen es hat viele junge
wahlkämpfer gegeben und die hat monat
neubauer in ihrer rede angesprochen was
für ein ergebnis
was für ein sound sehr lieben
vielen dank an alle die diesen
vertrauensvorschuss gegenüber den grünen
in nordrhein westfalen ausgesprochen
haben danke an alle wählerinnen und
wählern unseren starken landesverbandes
vielen dank
und für diesen vertrauensvorschuss
um wie viel kommt der hart gearbeitet
hier in nrw
und geheim gemerkt
dass das was unsere
vertreterinnen und vertreter in der
bundesregierung als politik stil leben
nämlich ehrlich zu kommunizieren viele
zu behalten und trotzdem pragmatische
wege zu finden aber vor allem haltung
und kompass zu haben in krisenzeiten
dass es uns hier in nordrhein westfalen
gelungenes dass sie menschen in nrw uns
das auch zutrauen und das ist ein
riesiger riesige auftrag an uns aus
diesem vertrauensvorschuss jetzt weiter
hart zu arbeiten um in einer nächsten
landesregierung endlich eine politik auf
höhe der zeit zu machen für die menschen
in nordrhein westfalen für die
wirtschaft in nordrhein westfalen
natürlich so daher der mona neubaur die
spitzenkandidatin der grünen hier in
nordrhein westfalen die zwölf prozent
plus rund zwölf prozent dazu gewonnen
hat und sich da erkennbar freut und
einen teil auch tatsächlich ab gibt
dieses erfolgs an die bundespolitik da
fragen wir doch mal nach matthias
fornoff woher kommt dieser große erfolg
der grünen die ja hier vor fünf jahren
im land sehr schwach war ja es wird das
beste ergebnis der grünen in nordrhein
westfalen überhaupt werden das kann man
jetzt schon sagen oder lohnt es sich auf
jeden fall mal zu gucken woran es denn
liegt wir schauen wir mal auf die
bewertung von spitzenpolitikerinnen und
-politikern und der partei im land und
im bund die grüne spitzenpolitikerin
hier +9 0,9 auf der skala von +5 bis -5
die grünen im land mit dem gleichen wert
jetzt zur bundespolitik robert habeck
plus 2,4 das ist ein sehr sehr guter
wert und die grünen im bund 1,5 man kann
also schon sehen an diesen zahlen es gab
rückenwind aus berlin aber eben nicht
nur und das sehen wir in der nächsten
grafik denn da gucken wir auf den
unterschied zwischen 2022 und vor fünf
jahren 2017 heute wir haben es gerade
gesehen monat 90 die grünen 0,9 vor fünf
jahren die spitzenkandidatin sylvia
löhrmann mit negativer bewertung und die
grünen bei 0,0 es ist nicht alles aus
berlin gekommen sondern manches
tatsächlich auch hausgemacht noch eine
letzte grafik haben wir um zu zeigen
woher denn die wählerinnen und wähler
der grünen kommen
wer heute die grünen gewählt hatte hat
vor fünf jahren die spd gewählt das sind
ungefähr 300 30.000 stimmen das ist der
größte block der neu dazugekommen ist
für die grünen
280.000 andere da sind auch linke und
fdp mit dabei und nichtwähler 240.000
das sind die drei großen blöcke aus
denen die grünen dazu gewonnen haben
dankeschön interessante analyse
ergebnisse so und jetzt schauen wir beim
reigen durch die partei natürlich noch
zur afd die hier auch verloren hat 55 6
prozent
so ganz gesichert ist sie noch nicht mal
im landtag peter böhme ist dort wurde
das aufgenommen ja der vergleich mit dem
fußball von der cdu von vorhin der passt
ja eigentlich auch ganz gut denn als das
ergebnis bekannt wurde da brach hier
wirklich frenetischer jubel aus die
parteispitze und die landes und bundes
spitze lagen sich in den armen
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer
sicher leichter ans herz gefasst und das
ist ja nicht verwunderlich weil
glücklicherweise hat die partei jahr 1,5
bis zwei prozent verloren da war wohl
dann doch die zuversicht die vorher
gezeigt jedoch geringer und dem motto
salopp gesagt vor dem abstieg dann doch
ein bisschen größer also hier die afd
freut sich
ja danke schön peter böhme für den
eindruck und der bundesvorsitzende tino
kubala dem wir gerade schon in den
bildern sahen ist jetzt zu uns ins
wahlstudio hergekommen stimmenanteil
kubala zusammen also 7,4 prozent waren
es vor fünf jahren jetzt darunter
55 so ganz sicher ist es noch nicht mal
ob sie im landtag bleiben letzte woche
in schleswig holstein haben wir auch
gesprochen da sind sie rausgeflogen sie
können nicht zufrieden sein wir sind
erstmal zufrieden ist aller voraussicht
nach doch reicht das wir einziehen
werden also dass hier auch mal
herzlichen dank an unsere welt aber
haben viele neue gesichter die in den
landtag einziehen werden also es wird
weiter eine alternative hier im landtag
geben das ist wichtig gleichwohl sind
wir natürlich in gänze nicht zufrieden
da werden wir uns die nächsten tage
natürlich auch unterhalten müssen
inwieweit wird jedoch eine initiative
west auch hier brauchen ja das ist
interessant ich sprach letzte woche
nämlich auch an
sie wollen volkspartei seien auch im
westen sind da aber weit von entfernt er
bleibt die afg schwach und es gibt ja
jetzt solche forderungen schon in ihrer
partei offensive west was haben sie vor
wir wollen sie aus dieser krise
herauskommen ja das wird eine starke
diskussion auf dem nächsten
bundesparteitag sein wo wir einen
bundesvorstand wählen und da wird genau
das soll zur sprache kommen das ist
natürlich auch die ergebnisse aus dem
osten zumindest zweistellige ergebnis
hier im westen auch haben wollen
gleichwohl ist es natürlich hier
schwieriger gleichwohl haben wir ja mit
anderen voraussetzungen zu kämpfen wir
müssen die regionalen und die lokalen
unterschiede und auch ein bisschen
akzeptieren vielleicht unterschiedliche
wahlkämpfe machen und das werden wir die
nächsten wochen alles analysieren es
gibt es gab sehr erfolgreiche jahre für
die afd ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut
dieses ist jetzt tatsächlich die neunte
mal in folge in der bei der die afg
verliert wenn man die bundestagswahl mit
nimmt sogar die zehnte die sind seit
november 2009 10 parteichef bei allen
wahlen danach hair group hamburg 2020
ginge immer der balken nach unten müssen
sie dafür als parteichef jetzt nicht
grundsätzlichere neue antworten finden
als immer nur das einzelergebnis zu
bewerten das habe ich gerade gesagt dass
wir das ganze in der partei machen
werden auf dem bundesparteitag damit wie
gesagt diese diskussionen kommen und
natürlich mitmachen uns diese ergebnisse
in gänze nicht zufrieden aber wir haben
es natürlich schwieriger wir werden vom
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk kaum zur
podiumsdiskussion eingeladen also dass
ich auch in replik an sie wir wären ja
auch kaum in irgendeiner weise dort zu
wort kommen zu wort also alternative
meinung sind wahrscheinlich im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk nicht
gewünscht und deswegen haben wir
natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger als
die anderen kleinen partei
von ihnen deswegen ist ja hier mal da
ist wenigstens habe ich mal die
gelegenheit das hier live im deutschen
tor ist der spaß und ich weiß jetzt mal
zurück denn sie ist stehen hier und wir
diskutieren heute eingeladen so dann
halten wir das jetzt einfach mal fest
mit kritik können sich nicht sonderlich
gut umgehen das stelle ich auch nicht
dann schauen wir jetzt nicht mehr zur
afg sondern gehen zu den grünen die hier
zweistellige gewinne dazu gewonnen haben
und ich bin in berlin verbunden mit der
bundesvorsitzenden ricarda lang so
letzte woche in schleswig-holstein
kräftig dazu gewonnen jetzt in nordrhein
westfalen die meisten zugewinne der
trend ist grün derzeit in frage frau
lang was machen sie damit
ja wir haben das beste historisch beste
ergebnis in nordrhein-westfalen wir
hatten vor einer woche das historisch
beste ergebnis in schleswig holstein und
ich glaube das zeigt dass die menschen
davon überzeugt sind dass wir antworten
auf der höhe der zeit haben was machen
wir damit diesen kurs weiterfahren und
vor allem dieses riesige projekt das wir
uns vorgenommen haben dieses land
klimaneutral zu machen jetzt in einer
landesregierung in nordrhein westfalen
dem bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland
tatsächlich in die tat umzusetzen und
damit nrw zur ersten klimaneutralen
industrieregionen ganz europa zu machen
da verlangen wir merkten die freude an
die form fragen hier haben gezeigt dass
die grüne arbeit in der ampel regierung
in berlin die von vizekanzler robert
habeck zum beispiel auch der
außenministerin schon zum erfolg hier in
nordrhein westfalen beigetragen hat das
hat frau neubauer ja auch gerade selbst
gesagt wenn das so ist verlangen können
die grünen dann in nrw jetzt mit der cdu
zusammengehen schreit das doch nicht
hier nach einer ampel
wir sind im wahlkampf mit einem ganz
klaren kurs der eigenständigkeit
angetragen wir wurden mit diesem kurs
gewählt und das sind wir jetzt auch den
wählerinnen und wähler entschuldigt dass
wir den durchhalten das heißt für uns
ist klar mit wem wir am ende regieren
das hängt einzig und allein von einer
sache ab und zwar wer überzeugend bereit
ist mit uns gemeinsam den weg in eine
klimaneutrale und digitale zukunft zu
gehen mehr soziale gerechtigkeit zu
schaffen und den zu zusammenhalt in nrw
zu stärken aber da sind sie offen ob das
dann cdu oder spd ist frau hat gesagt in
einem unserer beiträge es ist fast
unentschieden wäre dann am ende
ministerpräsident ist ist das so
hauptsache regieren
entscheidend ist es natürlich nicht weil
es geht darum dass wir gesagt haben am
ende ist nicht entscheidend wer in der
staatskanzlei ist sondern ob wir eine
regierung auf den weg bekommen die
wandel endlich nicht mehr nur aushält
sondern ihm aktiv gestaltet also die
erneuerbaren energien ausbaut die für
bezahlbare mieten sorgt wie uns
unabhängig macht von russischen
forcieren das heißt es geht nicht darum
hauptsache regieren sondern es geht
darum mit den richtigen inhalten zu
regieren und davon werden unsere
entscheidung abhängig machen
sagt die bundesvorsitzende der grünen
verlangen herzlichen dank nach berlin so
jetzt schauen wir zur fdp hier in
nordrhein westfalen carsten rüger kann
uns noch mal schildern wie dafür
wirklich schlechte ergebnis aufgenommen
wurde ein bitterer abend bei der fdp
mit ina absolutes entsetzen bei den
liberalen hier betretenes schweigen als
das ergebnis gezeigt wurde 5,5 prozent
knapp nur über der fünf prozent hürde
weniger als die hälfte dessen was man
2017 eingefahren hat und ebenfalls
absolutes entsetzen bei den liberalen
als sie dann sein was der
hauptkonkurrent die grünen eingefahren
haben allen ist ihr klar geworden die
grünen sind jetzt der königsmacher der
ministerpräsident ist kann auf die
liberalen komplett verzichten mit den
grünen regieren die fdp spielt also gar
keine rolle mehr einfach nur schrecklich
sagt er ein liberaler und ich habe ein
interessantes gespräch zwischen zwei ein
bisschen mit gehört er sagt der eine ist
schlimmer als das worst case szenario
was ich mir vorgestellt habe er meinte
damit unter sechs prozent
korrigierte in der andere liberale und
sagte du das worst case szenario das
kann noch kommen dass wir komplett raus
fliegen und beide meinten übereinstimmen
da muss ganz bescheiden sein bei diesem
wäre ein so schlechtes ergebnis einfährt
er kann nicht über koalition regierung
nachdenken man sagte mir wir müssen
jetzt einfach nur zittern und wenn am
ende doch irgendjemand noch bei uns
anklopfen sollte uns brauchen könnte
dann wäre das schon ein großes glück ja
danke schön katzen für die eindrücke ist
bleibt noch eine zitterpartie die gp ist
noch nicht gesichert im landtag können
wir denn schon sagen matthias woher die
verluste kommen ja es gibt zumindest
ziemlich deutliche hinweise wird tina
und das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an die
bewertung von spitzenkandidat und partei
war sehen wir in diesem jahr 2022 dem
fdp-spitzenkandidaten joachim stammt mit
einer bewertung von 0,4 christian
lindner hatte vor fünf jahren 1,4 das
ist eine ganz andere liga und das
betrifft auch die fdp im land die jetzt
auf 0,2 nur kommt und damals auf
0,7 das also erklärt es ein bisschen was
den bund und das land betrifft wir
schauen aber jetzt auch noch mal wer
wählte die fdp denn nach alter das ist
aus der wahltagsbefragung die
sogenannten exit-polls das sind 20.000
interviews anonymisiert aus dem man
unter anderem auch die altersstruktur
absehen kann wer hat die fdp gewählt wir
sehen hier ganz unten durchgängig
verluste in allen altersgruppen aber bei
den jüngeren die geringsten verluste
minus 1 punkt und bei den älteren über
60 die stärksten verluste - 9 und das
erklärt weil das natürlich die größeren
wählerinnen wählergruppen sind diese
hier woher diese verluste fdp auch
kommen danke schön verloren sicherlich
auch an die cdu die ein wenig
hinzugewinnen kann der abstand zur spd
jetzt bei rund 7 prozent das ist doch
relativ deutlich und jetzt halb gehen
wir jetzt nochmal zur cdu wulf schmiese
mit dem innenminister
bei uns ist der innenminister von
nordrhein-westfalen herbert reul heraus
das hätte auch ihr sieg sein können wenn
sie der kandidat gewesen wären sie ja
fast mal danach aus es war doch mein
sieg war unser sieg wir haben gemeinsam
gesiegt wir hätten genauso gemeinsam
verloren das tolle war ja das war nach
der der wechsel den wir machen mussten
kein streit kein konflikt hatten das war
wahrscheinlich das wesentliche warum es
jetzt funktioniert hat wir haben die
ganze strecke verlässliches
zusammengearbeitet in der cdu mit der
fdp und der wähler fand's gut sie sind
ein alter profi wenn es jetzt doch noch
für rot-grün reichen sollte halten sie
das für möglich dass die grünen auch aus
rücksicht auf die bundesregierung doch
noch rot grün machen ich habe bisher die
grünen immer kennen gelernt als leute
die sich an inhalt die verlässliche
partner wollen wir haben ja hier
erfahrung mit der spd schon nach den
letzten jahren macht man mal in aller
ruhe hat und zu glauben dass man mit dem
2 der abgestürzte zusammenarbeiten ich
glaube die bürgerinnen bürger finden das
komisch vielen dank nochmal westfalens
innenminister räubers und damit zurück
zum studium ja danke wulff so abgestürzt
nicht es sind verluste für die spd drei
prozentpunkte und es gibt noch eine
option zum regieren und die will die spd
auf jeden fall auch nutzen wenn es dann
rechnerisch möglich ist das können wir
gleich vertiefen damit professor portier
jetzt höre ich aber dass wir eine erste
hochrechnung haben um 18 0 27 und die
waren uns natürlich an jamaika absolut
hier kommen die neuen zahlen
hochrechnungen für nordrhein-westfalen
18 uhr 27 demnach kommt die cdu auf 35
prozent die spd auf
27,9 die fdp auf 5,4 die afg auf 5,5 die
grünen auf 18,2 die linke auf 2,0 und
die anderen auf 6 prozent wir schauen
uns mal gewinne und verluste an denn da
ist ja sehr sehr viel bewegung drin die
cdu war schon stärkste partei gewinnt
noch mal zwei punkte dazu die spd
verliert mehr als drei punkte die fdp
verliert satt minus 7,2 punkte
auch die afg verliert nicht ganz so viel
1,9 die grünen gewinnen zu ihrem
rekordergebnis dazu 11,8 punkte die
linke verliert zwei kann man noch ein
letztes mal war sie knapp gescheitert
mit 4,9 diesmal scheitert sie klar und
jetzt schauen wir mal was das heißt für
die sitzverteilung im düsseldorfer
landtag
199 sitze waren es bisher wir gehen
davon aus das bleibt so 76 für die cdu
60 für die spd 12 für die fdp und
ebenfalls zwölf für die afb wenn denn
beide die fünf-prozent-hürde schaffen
was noch nicht ganz klar ist und 39
sitze für die grünen jetzt gucken wir
mal alles was das heißt für das regieren
in nordrhein westfalen für welches
bündnis würde es den reichen bisher
haben reagiert cdu und fdp die kommen
auf 88 sitze werden die fdp drin ist das
reicht nicht 100 braucht man um die
absolute mehrheit zum regieren zu
erreichen schwarz grün schafft das
locker 100 15 sitze rot-grün schafft es
ganz knapp nicht da fehlt derzeit nur
ein sitz und wenn afd oder fdp oder gar
beide nicht in den landtag kommen dann
sieht das noch mal wieder ganz anders
aus da bis das klarer für rot grün rot
grün mit der fdp also die ampel käme auf
111 wenn die fdp im landtag ist und
würde es ebenfalls schaffen die
wahlbeteiligung übrigens ist deutlich
gesunken um 9 punkte auf 56 prozent
dankeschön matthias also das war die
erste hochrechnung und um halb sieben
ist das natürlich stoff um das mal kurz
sacken zu lassen und zu gucken wo stehen
wir jetzt wir haben gesehen die cdu hat
doch einen deutlicheren abstand
hinbekommen zur spd die aber haben wir
vom generalsekretär gehört ist wild
entschlossen an machtoptionen auch zu
nutzen und den anspruch zu erheben ja
ihr zu regieren jetzt dazu kommen zu
recht wenn sie die mädchen bekommt mit
den grünen können sie natürlich diese
verhandlungen angehen es wird von den
grünen dann abhängen mit wem sie am ende
votieren aber vom gesamtergebnis her
wird es schwer darstellbar sein denn das
sieht ja nach einem politischen erdbeben
gegen die berliner ampel aus fdp
dramatisch verliert und die spd auch und
im moment reicht es auch nicht haben wir
gerade gesehen für rot-grün
möglicherweise wenn die fdp oder die afc
noch aus dem landtag heraus fällt was
wir im moment noch nicht wissen dann in
der tat geringe nur jamaika ja und dann
mit so schwachen liberalen auch das ist
politisch schwer vorzustellen die
liberalen müssten wir wieder ein lager
wechsel praktisch vornehmen der ihn
offenbar im bund ja auch nicht bekommst
du nicht angerechnet wird von den
wählern wenn man jetzt plötzlich zur spd
wechseln würde sie unwahrscheinlich es
sieht nach kiwis aus also wie in hessen
regiert wird
wir müssen den weiteren abend abwarten
denn das ist natürlich interessant wie
sich alles ausstellen wird sie haben
schon gesagt herr professor korte das
ist im grunde jetzt auch eine klatsche
für die ampel die da regiert der
schutzeffekt hat nicht richtig getragen
das sieht man hier ja was muss jetzt
berlin für schlüsse daraus ziehen ja
auch in folge in der folge von kiel bis
hier ist das gleichermaßen erkennbar die
spd profitiert offenbar nicht von einem
scholz effekt sonst wäre hier ablesbar
gewesen und die fdp auch nicht offen
weiß auch wirtschafts und finanzpolitik
als kompetenzfeld er die grünen rüber
gewandert und bei der fdp ist ja so dass
lindner seine politische macht auf nrw
fixiert und passiert hatte zu fern ist
die fdp sehr stark im trudel
dankeschön für den moment professor
kommt und wir müssen noch mal eine
gratis korrigieren für die cdu reicht es
mit den grünen für schwarz grün da ist
jamaika nicht notwendig das ist
interessant gewesen vielleicht noch die
nachfrage dass in schleswig-holstein
daniel günther durchaus jamaika anbietet
obwohl es gar nicht braucht ja für die
transformation vorhaben eine breite
integration und es ist sowas wie
kollaboratives neues regieren das hatte
er ja eingeübt nicht nach schnittmengen
zu suchen sondern gemeinsam projekt
ideen umzusetzen was offenbar ankommt in
der bevölkerung dankeschön professor
karte für moment und jetzt hören wir
dass der wahlgewinner von der cdu
hendrik wüst auch jetzt vor seine partei
tritt hören wir mal
es ist noch nicht so weit
ja ok
so
es war angekündigt dass hendrik wüst
ja jetzt sehen was aus
die menschen haben uns ganz klar zur
stärksten kraft gemacht das ist der
auftrag eine künftige regierung zu
bilden und zu führen
dank für den menschen für diesen klaren
vertrauensbeweis
danke ganz herzlich im kabinett danke
der fraktion der parteizentrale den
kandidatinnen und kandidaten
danke ganz herzlich all unseren
wahlkämpferin und wahlkämpfern team fuji
seit der hammer
[Applaus]
ein ganz herzlicher dank gilt an die fdp
wir haben in den letzten jahren unser
land gut regiert und gut vorangebracht
und wir haben das in einem
freundschaftlichen verhältnissen von
freundschaftlichen und verlässlichen
verhältnis getan und wir waren immer
verlässlich an den interessen der
menschen in diesem land orientiert ein
ganz herzlicher dank gilt auch meiner
frau kate vielen dank für deine stärke
[Applaus]
so hendrik wüst der hier heute platz
eins erobert hat bestätigt hat 35
prozent etwa mit einigem abstand zur spd
der fdp gerade noch einmal gedankt hat
und jetzt einen regierungsauftrag
ableitet das allerdings wird eben mit
der fdp nicht mehr gehen deshalb würde
es zu einem regierungswechsel in jedem
fall kommen so die cdu können wir uns
genauer anschauen sollten wir unbedingt
machen ist ja auch ein großer
wahlerfolgs für die cdu wir schauen mal
auf die bewertung von spitzenpolitikern
und partei in land und bund hendrik wüst
kommt auf der skala von +5 bis -5 also
von sehr gut ist sehr schlecht auf 1,8
friedrich merz als cdu-chef nur auf 0,2
die cdu im land auf gute 1,4 die cdu im
bund 1,1 was sagt uns die grafik es ist
ein hausgemachter erfolg mit nicht so
entscheidende unterstützung aus berlin
offensichtlich wer kann nordrhein
westfalen am besten voranbringen haben
wir gefragt und da sagen die befragten
die wahlberechtigten hier in nordrhein
westfalen 27 prozent das ist der
amtierende ministerpräsident hendrik
wüst thomas kutschaty trauen das 19
prozent am ehesten zu und auch das eine
typische zahl die wir in vielen grafiken
gesehen haben 25 prozent immerhin sehen
zwischen den cut beiden keinen
unterschied aber die cdu liegt halt auch
in dieser allgemeinen frage doch recht
deutlich vor der spd
interessant ja und thomas kutschaty der
spd herausforderer ist jetzt auch vor
seine anhänger getreten da rein
dank liebe
genossinnen und genossen
das tut an einem solchen abend verdammt
gut euch hier so jubeln zusehen und
unterstützen zu sehen herzlichen dank
für eure aufmunterung für euren applaus
vielen vielen dank dafür
ihr habt die ihr habt die erste
hochrechnung gerade mitbekommen das
ergebnis dieser landtagswahl ist leider
nicht so wie wir uns das vorgestellt
haben es gibt zwei parteien die zugelegt
haben nämlich die union die etwas
zugelegt hat und die grünen die ihr
ergebnis verdreifachte haben und
deswegen gehört es bei einem fairen
wettkampf auch dazu zunächst der cdu
hendrik wüst und mona neubaur von den
grünen zu ihren zugewinnen zu
gratulieren herzlichen glückwunsch an
grüne und cdu heute abend auch hier von
der spd
unser ergebnis liegt unter unseren
erwartungen und wir wollten stärkste
partei werden das ist uns nicht gelungen
uns trennt einige prozentpunkte von der
union tatsächlich aber eins steht auch
fest am heutigen abend
schwarz-gelb unser wahlziel nummer eins
abzuwählen das hat geklappt schwarz gelb
hat keine mehrheit mehr hier in
nordrhein westfalen
so das ist schon ein deutlicher hinweis
darauf thomas kutschaty war dass der im
moment in den hochrechnungen so etwa
sieben prozent hinter der cdu liegt aber
sagt ein wahlziel ist durchaus erreicht
nämlich schwarz gelb abzuwählen das
freilich liegt an der schwäche der fdp
jedenfalls klingt es nicht so als würde
er auf stecken wir haben vom
spd-generalsekretär aus berlin vorhin
schon gehört dass wenn es möglich ist
der anspruch zu regieren jedenfalls
gespräche zu führen durchaus erhoben
werden soll das mal der stand jetzt wir
wollen auf eine partei gucken die für
die es nicht gut steht letzte woche
nicht in schleswig holstein und auch
hier jetzt nicht in nordrhein westfalen
beim letzten mal ganz knapp gescheitert
jetzt bei 2 prozent in der hochrechnung
die linke und ich bin in berlin mit
janine wissler der parteivorsitzenden
verbunden grüße sie schöne frau bislang
den antrag chancen so
ihre partei das ist der eindruck nach
den beiden wahlen letzte woche in
schleswig holstein und auch hier in
nordrhein westfalen rutscht ein bisschen
richtung bedeutungslosigkeit ist die
beobachtung so ganz falsch
das ist heute abend einen sehr
enttäuschendes ergebnis für uns ein
bitteres ergebnis mein dank gilt
natürlich den wahlkämpferin in nordrhein
westfalen und den spitzenkandidaten dort
die im wahlkampf ja gekämpft haben um
jede stimme aber natürlich die partei
ist momentan in einer schwierigen
situation und wir müssen jetzt mit blick
auf den bundesparteitag die weichen
stellen dass wir wieder erfolgreich sein
können das heißt vertrauen
zurückgewinnen das heißt wieder mehr mit
klaren botschaften als mit streitereien
in der presse zu sein und ganz klar
politik zu machen für die mieterinnen
und mieter für die beschäftigten für
konsequenten klimaschutz und
umverteilung dass es unser auftrag und
ja da haben wir eine hohe verantwortung
nun ist die krise in der tat tief die
sie auch einräumen man hatte den
eindruck die linke wird nicht mehr
gewählt und sie wird auch gar nicht mehr
gebraucht beschleicht sich da zusätzlich
die sorge dass ihre partei vielleicht
schon geschichte ist
nein es gibt umfragen wonach eine linke
parteien deutschland ein potenzial von
19 bis 20 prozent hätte oder hat und die
frage ist wie können wir dieses
potenzial auch wieder erreichen ich
denke wenn man sich die politik der
ampel anschaut dann gibt es doch gerade
ganz viele soziale lehrstellen die
kindergrundsicherung kommt nicht die
versprochenen verbesserungen bei hartz
iv oder eben auch der konsequente
klimaschutz zudem reden wir gerade über
ein sondervermögen 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr braucht das doch eine
kraft in den parlamenten die da laut und
deutlich die stimme dagegen erhebt und
deshalb bin ich davon überzeugt dass
seine linke stimme gebraucht wird eine
stimme die auch den finger in die wunde
legt und deutlich macht dass es
alternativen zur bestehenden politik
gibt das muss die linke wieder werden da
müssen wir vertrauen zurück gewinnen
ganz klar aber eine solche stimme wird
gebraucht in der zeit in der die einen
immer reicher und andere immer ärmer
werden in den menschen sich sorgen
machen angesichts der steigenden preise
und viele gar nicht mehr wissen wie sie
ihre miete bezahlen
wir haben den pflegenotstand an dem sich
nichts verändert hat also von daher die
themen liegen ja eigentlich auf der
straße der wahlkampf aber vorbei frau
wissler und hier in nordrhein westfalen
sind sie nicht gewählt worden deshalb
noch einmal die frage hätten sie nach
dem rücktritt ihrer co vorsitzenden
henning welt so nicht entschieden den
neustart schon starten müssen den
neuanfang starten müssen einschließlich
der entscheidung selbst auch den weg
frei zu machen dafür ja wir haben ja im
nächsten monat einen bundesparteitag im
juni wo wir die weichen stellen wollen
sowohl inhaltlich damit wir wieder mit
klaren botschaften wahrzunehmen sind und
weniger durch zerstrittenheit aber
natürlich auch personell also der
parteitag steht an und den bereiten wir
jetzt vor
sagt die vorsitzende janine wissler
dankeschön nach berlin
dann sind wir glaube ich jetzt mit den
parteien
einmal haben wir den reigen voll gemacht
und wir schauen jetzt nochmal auf eine
stimme die interessantes mit blick nach
vorn bernd althusmann ist der
cdu-landesvorsitzende in niedersachsen
und stellvertretender ministerpräsident
in der spd geführten großen koalition in
niedersachsen
und dort herr althusmann wird anfang
oktober gewählt da ist tatsächlich die
nächste wahl jetzt sind sie der
spitzenkandidat was leiten sie jetzt aus
dem abend hier heute ab
zwei landtagswahlen hintereinander ein
klares votum für die cdu die cdu
stärkste kraft der nordrhein westfalen
ein toller wahlsieg auch glückwunsch an
die grünen und wir haben alle chancen
auch in niedersachsen können wir am ende
stärkste kraft werden das ist unser ziel
und daran werden wir arbeiten und alle
guten dinge sind drei also insofern drei
landtagswahlen mit guten ergebnissen für
die cdu sei eine gute grundlage und vor
allen dingen ein korrektiv für die ampel
dem moment keinen guten lauf hat ja wie
wichtig ist willig nachfragen nach ihrer
ansicht dieses ergebnis von hendrik wüst
auch für die bundes-cdu und auch für den
parteivorsitzenden friedrich marc
hendrik wüst das team höchst er hat toll
gekämpft die cdu stärkste kraft die spd
das historisch schlechteste ergebnis es
gibt keinen grund auf seiten spd zu
jubeln der kanzler hat letztendlich
nicht gezogen im wahlkampf also insofern
glaube ich schon dass mit hendrik wüst
mit friedrich merz mit dem gesamten team
der cdu deutschlands wir alle chance
haben auch die dritte landtagswahl in
deutschland in diesem jahr zu gewinnen
das war anfang des jahres ins alle im
saarland bekanntlich noch etwas schwerer
aus aber das gibt uns auf und ich bin
sehr optimistisch ich bin zuversichtlich
wir haben beim letzten mal im letzten
jahr auch die kommunalwahl in
niedersachsen deutlich gewonnen nach 40
jahren immer noch stärkste kraft
insofern hat die cdu das potenzial auch
in niedersachsen als stärkste kraft am
19 oktober den wahlsieg nach hause zu
bringen das ist ihr wunsch sie sind der
spitzenkandidat und wollen stephan weil
dort ablösen jetzt regieren sie ja in
einer großen koalition wäre das
eigentlich aus ihrer sicht auch eine
variante über die wird hier in nordrhein
westfalen ja so gar nicht diskutiert cdu
und spd zusammen würden sie wird das
empfehlen auch zu auszuloten
ich habe meinem freund hendrik wüst
keine ratschläge zu erteilen da wird
genau wissen was am heutigen abend macht
und vor allen dingen in den nächsten
tagen es geht darum jetzt eine stabile
regierung zu bilden alles andere wäre
ein starkes misstrauen gegenüber den
wählerinnen und wählern ich glaube
letztendlich dass die cdu ihren klaren
regierungsauftrag bekommen hat alle
denkbaren optionen müssen ausgelotet
werden ich denke schwarz grün oder ein
jamaika bündnis wäre ebenso denkbar aber
letztendlich in niedersachsen haben wir
auch nie an die große koalition gedacht
sie war politisch immer umstritten
keiner wollte sie es war keine
liebesheirat wir lieben uns auch heute
nicht sondern wir stehen im wettbewerb
miteinander also insofern große
koalition ist der denkbar schlechteste
fall wenn nichts anderes möglich ist
muss man sicherlich darüber nachdenken
aber ich denke hendrik wüst hat alle
optionen offen und er hat den klaren
regierungsauftrag von den wählerinnen
und wählern in nordrhein westfalen
halten hat sich in der bernd althusmann
für diese einschätzungen und jetzt
gucken wir gleich hier mal aus dem
fenster ich nehme sie mal mit den
hendrik wüst kommt jetzt hier in den
landtag natürlich dann auch zu unserer
19 uhr heute sendung in einer
viertelstunde und wird sich dann
natürlich hier den interviews stellen
kommt so da sehen wir ihnen gerade
kommt da ein bisschen applaus erwies
kurzfristig
wir freuen uns sehr über diesen klaren
auftrag der wählerinnen und wähler noch
viel klarer als es in den umfragen außer
dass gerade foto meine künftige
regierung bilden zu dürfen märz ihn
schon gratuliert heute
selbstverständlich
und dann kam war das gleich noch
vertiefen also er ist auf dem weg und
jetzt haben wir erst richtig
forschungsgruppe eine hochrechnungen
jetzt
aus nach die schauen wir uns an bettina
die neue hochrechnung die zweite an
diesem abend 18 uhr 45 die cdu bei 35,2
die spd bei 27,7 fdp 5,5 wäre damit im
landtag vertreten die afg mit 5,6 ebenso
das ist noch nicht hundertprozentig
sicher die grünen 17,9 prozent die linke
mit 2,2 prozent sicher wieder nicht drin
und die anderen insgesamt knapp 6
prozent wir schauen viel bewegung hier
auf die gewinne und verluste der cdu
kommt von einem starken ergebnis und
legt noch mal zu oft zwei um 2,2 punkte
die spd kommt von ihrem schlechtesten
ergebnis jemals in nrw und verliert noch
einmal 3,5 punkte die fdp mit sehr
deutlichen verlusten minus 7 punkte die
afg minus 1,8 und die grünen sind der
gewinner des abends was das betrifft mit
11,5 punkten zu gewinnen linke minus 2,7
wir schauen mal auf die sitzverteilung
im düsseldorfer landtag
199 sitze was bisher wir rechnen damit
jetzt erstmal weiter und demnach käme
die cdu auf 76 sitze die spd auf 60 die
fdp auf 12 die afd auf 12 beide noch mit
dem fragezeichen das ich genannt habe
und die grünen mit 39 sitzen was hieße
das fürs regieren in nordrhein westfalen
die senkrechte linie hier die zeigt die
absolute mehrheit die man mit 100 sitzen
hat die bisher regierende cdu fdp
regierung kommt auf 88 wenn die fdp denn
drin ist das reicht deutlich nicht
schwarz-grün würde sehr deutlich reichen
rot grün würde nicht reichen es fehlt
aber nur einen sitz kann sich im laufe
des abends also auch noch ändern spd
grüne und fdp werden die fdp drin ist
reicht ebenfalls deutlich
dankeschön dafür interessante zahlen und
jetzt schauen wir kurz noch mal zu den
grünen die größten wahlgewinner heute
abend und zu in arbeit ist
ja bei mir sind jetzt so viel und da
wird zu viel was hast du gedacht als das
ergebnis ich habe mich natürlich total
gefreut dass ein brillantes ergebnis für
uns was bei den anderen passiert dass es
überraschend aber damit können wir
arbeiten mit arbeiten heißt hast du
schon präferenz sagen also ich glaube
die präferenz ist für mich das was
unsere parteispitze am ende raus handelt
und grüne stimmen für grüne inhalte und
dass am ende das was für mich zählt
linke landesverband trotzdem scheinen
alle ihre sehr offen zu sein in alle
richtungen ist das richtig nein eine
richtung ja nicht wir haben uns klar
abgegrenzt und mit demokratinnen
arbeiten wir zusammen und wir müssen
schauen wo führt am ende reicht aber in
die regierung wollen wir natürlich um
dort linke inhalte umzusetzen was wäre
der wichtigste inhalt also ich denke
erst mal die 10 km oder zehn hektar
abstands wege also oder in kraft von
windkraft auf jeden fall ja das ist mit
gesundem menschenverstand glaube ich
nicht vereinbar so die grüne parteibasis
ist offen für alles das werden spannende
verhandlungen in düsseldorf
ja genau so ist es und spannende
verhandlungen hat auch hendrik wüst
folglich schönen guten abend cdu
westfalen und jetzt wirklich chancen
reicht das fortzusetzen wenn es ihnen
dann gelingt die grünen an die seite zu
holen hervis die cdu bleibt stärkste
kraft in nrw sie bauen das ein bisschen
aus wie erleichtert sind sie heute abend
ja das ist ein starkes votum und ich bin
sehr dankbar den wählerinnen für dieses
tolle ergebnis und für das vertrauen
auch in zukunft eine regierung bilden zu
dürfen bei wem bedanken sie sich heute
abend mehr bei daniel günther in
schleswig holstein oder bei friedrich
merz in berlin vor allen dingen danke
ich den wählerinnen und wählern in
nordrhein westfalen eine landtagswahl
mit ihren eigenen themen und wurst um
die kandidatinnen und kandidaten geht
die die parteien aufstellen also eine
klare landtagswahlen und deshalb der
klare dank an die wählerinnen und wähler
in nordrhein-westfalen und sie kriegen
das strahlen gar nicht mehr aus dem
gesicht sehe ich schon sie sind dank
sweater weise schon mal vorab gekommen
gleich in der 19 uhr wollen wir
natürlich auch noch die essentiellen
fragen des heutigen abends klären ich
will jetzt mal so fragen herr wüst sie
sind jan langen weg gegangen nrw und der
war auch gar nicht immer so ganz
gradlinig was bedeutet ihnen dieser
wahlerfolg heute abend persönlich bin
wirklich sehr sehr dankbar für dieses
klare votum natürlich müssen wir damit
jetzt auch klug umgehen man muss mit
respekt ein solches ergebnis annehmen
was gilt für uns alle jetzt und
natürlich muss man auch ein stück weit
demütig sein in einer solchen situation
aber der dank überwiegt natürlich klar
sie müssen demütig sein sagen sie denn
die spd sagt auch sie die spd habe das
erste wahlziel das nämlich schwarz gelb
die schwarz gelbe regierung nicht mehr
im amt bleiben kann schon mal erreicht
die spd wird also auch den anspruch
stellen eine regierung zu bilden haben
sie sich darauf eingestellt mit respekt
mit anstand muss man ein solches
ergebnis annehmen das gilt für alle
parteien die kandidiert haben und das
heißt eben auch anzuerkennen dass die
wählerinnen und wähler ein klares wort
gesprochen haben mit diesem starken
ergebnis um diesen klaren
regierungsauftrag für mich und die cdu
in nordrhein westfalen
nun hatte man im wahlkampf zuletzt schon
den eindruck dass sie ihr grünes herz so
richtig intensiv in den letzten wochen
entdeckt haben das war schon ein
bisschen vorbauen die ersten schritte
auf die grünen zu so will man der
regierungserklärung direkt nach meiner
wahl im oktober habe ich klar gesagt
dass das größte projekt unserer
generation ist die größte
herausforderung auch für dieses land im
besonderen klimaschutz und industrie mit
den guten arbeitsplätzen sozialer
sicherheit zu verbinden ist die
herausforderung unserer zeit der müssen
wir uns stellen dafür braucht man
natürlich ökologische kompetenz auf der
einen aber auch wirtschaftliche
kompetenz und das ist die größte
herausforderung der nächsten jahre und
danach richten wir uns auch aus mit wem
wir in zukunft zusammenarbeiten wollen
um dieses land auch in zukunft gut voran
zu bringen sie sagen sie haben gut mit
der fdp regiert daniel günther in
schleswig holstein sagt jetzt er möchte
eigentlich jamaika fortsetzen obwohl das
gar nicht gebraucht wäre das für sie
auch eine idee die fdp im boot zu halten
ob schon sehr starke verluste
eingefahren hat ich werde mit allen
demokraten einer demokratischen parteien
darüber reden wie wir unser land in
zukunft gut voranbringen und die
richtigen antworten auf die
herausforderung geben die akuten
herausforderungen auf die schwierige
situation die sich aus den krieg in der
ukraine ergeben aber eben auch auf die
große herausforderung klimaschutz und
industrieland zu versöhnen werde mit
allen demokratischen parteien sprechen
du bist vielen dank für den moment sie
laufen bitte nicht weit weg 19 uhr
unsere heute -sendung das ist klar danke
schonmal für den vorab besuch und jetzt
sind wir gleich eigentlich noch mit dem
fdp-bundesvorsitzenden christian lindner
in berlin verabredet gucken jetzt aber
erstmal zu carsten rüger und hier in
nordrhein westfalen zur fdp
ich habe ja marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann die düsseldorferin ist
und im fdp bundesvorstand ist wie
erklären sie sich diesen absturz da
regiert die fdp in schleswig-holstein
jamaika-koalition hier in nrw in einer
schwarz gelben koalition beide male wird
sie abgestraft bekommt das regieren der
fdp nicht was schwierig ist wenn
polarisiert wird in beiden bundesländern
gegen es darauf ihr wird
ministerpräsident und das ist für uns
immer problematisch aber wie sieht es
aus jetzt ist die fdp überhaupt gar
nicht mehr gebraucht da kann daniel
günther in schleswig holstein in kiel
mit den grünen ohne der fdp regieren
hier kann dass herr wüst auch machen ist
man irgendwie bedeutungslos hatte die
liberale idee die freien demokraten sind
alles andere bedeutungslos und wir
arbeiten viel aber wir müssen natürlich
jetzt analysieren was ist passiert der
ist wohin gegangen das muss man auch
ganz offen und selbstkritisch machen und
dann werden wir weiter arbeiten erst als
über koalition macht man sich das gar
keine gedanken muss erstmals überhaupt
reinkommt ins parlament wir werden ins
parlament kommen wenn ich ganz sicher
und die koalition oder was möglich ist
entscheidet die landespolitiker
entscheiden nicht wir und wie gesagt hat
keinen sinn schütteln krone aufsetzen
weiterarbeiten vielen dank das war marie
agnes strack zimmermann und damit zurück
zu dir ja sie ist sicher dass es dabei
bleibt dass die
fdf dp entschuldigung im landtag von
nordrhein-westfalen bleibt ganz
ausgemacht ist das allerdings in der tat
noch nicht das bleibt eine zitterpartie
für die liberalen hier in nordrhein
westfalen jetzt können wir mal zur spd
eine interessante analyse bieten
matthias fonger vater sehr spannende
zahlen mal mit den personen an dem
amtsinhaber und seinem herausforderer
und da sehen wir in den kategorien wer
ist sympathischer wer ist glaubwürdiger
wer hat mehr sachverstand jeweils
hendrik wüst vor thomas kutschaty das
sind keine welten dazwischen aber es
sind doch deutliche abstände und
bezeichnet für vieles hier im lande ist
auch hier dieser blaue balken einen
riesengroßen unterschied haben viele
oder die meisten gar nicht gesehen
zwischen den beiden wir schauen auf die
wahltagsbefragung und die altersstruktur
derer die spd gewählt haben und sehen
hier bei den unter 30-jährigen deutliche
verluste - 6 auch bei den 30 bis 44
jährigen und bei den 45 bis 59 jährigen
nur bei den älteren über 60 sind die
verluste klein jetzt ist aber auch mal
interessant sich anzugucken wen haben
denn die unter 30-jährigen hier in
nordrhein westfalen gewählt
die cdu 18 prozent spd 21 fdp 12 d 5
grüne 25 prozent und das ist eigentlich
die zahl des abends wenn das sind 15
punkte mehr als vor fünf jahren
die spd wie gesagt hat da sogar ja noch
verloren dankeschön matthias
interessante zahlen die hat auch lars
klingbeil mitverfolgt in berlin der
bundesvorsitzende der spd den ich
begrüße die namen tackling war
ja vor einer woche war das mit
krachenden niederlage für die spd in
schleswig-holstein und dann schon alle
gesagt das wird jetzt der cdu zugute
kommen jetzt ist es so dass sie so bei
rund 28 prozent gelandet sind in
nordrhein-westfalen und sind damit
vermutlich nicht so zufrieden werden wie
es klarer gewünscht oder
natürlich haben wir für ein besseres
ergebnis gekämpft allerdings hat sich
die prozentzahl die wir jetzt bekommen
und mal gucken wie die entwicklung am
abend sind aber sieht danach aus dass
wir zweiter kraft werden und das hat
sich ja angedeutet in den letzten tagen
und gleichwohl muss man ja sagen es
steht noch nichts fest für
nordrhein-westfalen außer dass die
amtierende landesregierung die schwarz
gelbe landesregierung abgewählt wurde
und den rest müssen wir jetzt gucken und
wir warten mal bis das amtliche ergebnis
dann vorliegt sie leiden ganz klar ein
anspruch zum regieren wenn es dann
rechnerisch steht auch aus diesem
ergebnis ab gleichwohl die cdu ob schon
die cdu den punkte vorne liegt
schwarz-gelb ist abgewählt worden heute
abend und wissen wochen ist deutlich
geworden in befragung dass die menschen
in nordrhein westfalen
zwischen dass man ein politikwechsel
wird in nordrhein westfalen und jetzt
müssen wir wirklich gucken bis am ende
alles ausgezählt ist die wählerinnen und
wähler haben jetzt entschieden aber das
ergebnis liegt eben noch nicht
detailliert vor ob rot grün möglich ist
ob es möglich ist einen solchen
politikwechsel in nordrhein westfalen
noch zu erreichen das musste miteinander
besprochen werden da wird verhandelt
also das werden jetzt wochen auch in den
nrw hoffentlich verhandelt was am besten
für die bürgerinnen und bürger ist aber
heute ist erst mal vieles unklar das ist
noch so aber eines kann man vielleicht
schon ablesen dass doch die ampel
der test nicht besonders gut ausgefallen
ist oder wenn man hier in nordrhein
westfalen sieht als signal für den bund
ich glaube dass es vor allem erstmal
landespolitische entscheidungen sind die
eine rolle spielen ich war ja auch viele
nordrhein westfalen unterwegs dass über
die frage geredet worden wie kann man
industrie arbeitsplätze erhalten und
trotzdem klimaneutralität erreichen wie
ist das mit dem bezahlbaren wohnen wie
ist das auch mit dem gesundheitssystem
in nordrhein westfalen das waren die
großen themen über die ich geredet habe
und dachte ich angesprochen wurde was
wir allerdings sehen zur frage der fdp
es ist handfest in den letzten tagen
durch eine intensive kampagne gelungen
doch noch ganz viele stimmen von der fdp
zur union zu ziehen ob man so mit einem
koalitionspartner auf landesebene umgeht
das muss er wüst beantworten aber dass
die fdp da genau hinschaut und das auch
für sich so analysiert und dann
möglicherweise darauf setzen sie
vielleicht die pferde wechselt dann in
einer ampel regierung erklären weil das
ist in der tat offen ich danke ihnen
erst mal für die ersten einschätzungen
aus der
dankeschönabend so herr professor korte
wir haben noch eine gute minute bis 19
uhr sendung und können vielleicht daran
mal kurz anknüpfen würden sie schon
sagen das ergebnis jetzt ist doch eher
eine klatsche für die ampel in berlin ja
und das ist ein geradezu triumphaler
siegeszug für die zweitklässler für
habeck und vermutlich auch für frau
berbalk also die grünen gewinnen jetzt
in serie offenbar profitieren von der
ampel die spd verliert dramatisch durch
die appel konstellation und wir haben
wieder im schatten des krieges jahr
gewählt dass er die themen nach vorne
gebracht aber es hat wieder den
amtsbonus offenbar bestätigt obwohl der
klein war
das ist in der tat war die gewinne sind
hier nicht so besonders groß sie sagen
der gewinner des heutigen abends das
sind ganz klar die grünen eindeutig
verdreifacht das ergebnis das ist
triumphal das ist etwas ganz besonderes
die waren in den letzten jahren oft
umfrage helden das zeigt sich aber nicht
mehr die umbau dass der gesellschaft die
transformationsprozesse werden mit ihnen
verbunden und über vor neubauer hier in
diesem land offenbar auch wirtschafts
und finanzpolitische kompetenz
gleichwohl ist jetzt kurz vor 19 uhr
noch nicht klar werde nordrhein
westfalen regieren wird nur die alte
regierung ist abgewählt das steht fest
das steht fest da professor korte wir
werden gleich nochmal gelegenheit haben
nach unserer 19 uhr heute sendung in
mainz das zu vertiefen das lohnt noch
später dann auch noch die berliner runde
die heute abend besonders spannend es
und jetzt gebe ich sehr gerne nach mainz
zu den kollegen zur heute sendung um 19
uhr bis gleich
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
paris nordrhein westfalen hat gewählt
und damit herzlich willkommen und sport
gibt's mit norbert lehmann mit dem
spannenden aufstiegskampf in der zweiten
liga bremen hat es nach schalke direkt
geschafft aber als erstes schauen wir
auf das große thema heute die wahl im
bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland
komfortabler vorsprung für wüst bei der
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen wird
seine cdu stärkste kraft an den grünen
führt nach rekordergebnis wohl kein weg
vorbei
zwei neue im klub trotz türkischer
skepsis steht aus sicht der nato den
beitritt finnlands und schwedens nichts
mehr im weg finnland hat seine bewerbung
offiziell beschlossen
und politisch wie nie zuvor beim
eurovision songcontest gewinnt die
ukraine klar weil die tv zuschauer sie
mit punkten überschüttet
[Applaus]
die cdu liegt stand jetzt klar vorn bei
der landtagswahl in nordrhein-westfalen
verluste dagegen bei der spd den größten
zugewinn haben die grünen gemacht und
ihr bisher bestes ergebnis in dem
bundesland eingefahren bei fdp und afd
ist noch offen ob sie tatsächlich den
sprung über die fünf-prozent-hürde
schaffen schauen wir uns das alles in
zahlen an matthias fornoff in düsseldorf
hat die aktuelle hochrechnung für uns
matthias wie schneiden die parteien
genauer ja guten abend wir schauen uns
die neue hochrechnung an 19 uhr und
sehen dass die cdu hier 35,3 prozent
kommt klar stärkste partei ist die spd
27,5 die fdp mit kommt auf 5,5 und wäre
damit im landtag drin die afg mit
5,6 auch bei beiden muss man sagen die
briefwahl ergebnisse liegen noch nicht
vor es gibt noch ein kleines
fragezeichen
beide haben sich aber so stabilisiert
die grünen bei 17,9 prozent linke klar
nicht im landtag 2,2 prozent und andere
zusammen 6 prozent jetzt gucken wir mal
auf gewinne und verluste die waren
erheblich die cdu kam von einem starken
ergebnis und legt noch mal mehr als zwei
punkte zu die spd kam von ihrem
schlechtesten ergebnis überhaupt in nrw
und verliert noch einmal 3,7 punkte die
fdp mehr als halbiert - 7,1 punkte die
ar stehen mit verlusten minus 1,8 und
die grüne mit sehr großen zugewinnen
11,5 punkte im vergleich zur letzten
landtagswahl
die linke minus 2,75 jahren hatten sie
4,9 prozent waren knapp gescheitert
diesmal sind sie klar draußen und wie
sieht es nach derzeitigem stand mit der
sitzverteilung aus welche koalition wenn
möglich schauen wir mal auf den
düsseldorfer landtag da rechnen wir mit
199 sitzen so wie auch in der letzten
legislaturperiode und demnach käme die
cdu auf 76 sitze die spd auf 60 die fdp
auf 12 auch die afg auf 12 werden sie
beide drin sind und die grünen auf 39
sitze was heißt das für das regieren in
nordrhein westfalen und da es wichtig
diese senkrechte linie das ist die
absolute mehrheit die man braucht zum
regieren 100 sitze die derzeit
amtierende regierung cdu mit fdp 88
erreicht das deutlich nicht ist also
abgewählt schwarz-grün überschreitet
diese dinge sehr deutlich 115 sitze 100
braucht man und das sehen wir hier spd
und grüne 99 da fehlt ein sitz kann sich
im laufe des abends natürlich noch
ändern spd grüne und fdp 111 auch das
würde deutlich gleichen übrigens die
wahlbeteiligung ist deutlich gesunken um
9 punkte auf jetzt 56 prozent dank
matthias fornoff so sieht es also aus
nach der aktuellen hochrechnung die cdu
also stärkste kraft aber ob
ministerpräsident wies auch tatsächlich
die nächste regierung anführen wird ist
noch offen für schwarz grün würde es
reichen aber auch eine spd geführte
regierung wäre möglich und alle spitzen
kandidaten und eine kandidatin sind
jetzt in unserem zdf studio in
düsseldorf bei bettina schausten und
dort fertig jetzt übergeben
vielen dank jana und wir beginnen mit
dem cdu-ministerpräsidenten hendrik wüst
ja jetzt die chance hat das auch zu
bleiben schönen guten abend also die cdu
bleibt stärkste kraft aber wir haben es
gesehen schwarz-gelb ihre regierung ist
abgewählt wie wollen sie es schaffen
jetzt die grünen ins boot zu holen
während sehr dankbar für dieses starke
ergebnis meiner partei wir legen noch
einmal zu ganz klar stärkste partei und
damit auch ein klarer regierungsauftrag
ein klarer auftrag eine neue regierung
zu bilden und zu führen und ich werde
auf alle demokratischen parteien zugehen
um eine neue eine starke regierung zu
bilden die in der lage ist mit den
themen dieser zeit aber auch mit der
besonders schwierigen situation aktuell
wegen des kriegs in der ukraine
verantwortungsvoll umzugehen
thomas kutschaty spitzenkandidat der spd
das schlechteste ergebnis für die
sozialdemokratie nordrhein westfalen als
armin laschet ähnliches im bund
vergangenes jahr passiert ist für die
christdemokraten haben sie gesagt ist
eine anmaßung darauf den auftrag zur
regierungsbildung abzuleiten das gilt
jetzt für sie erstmal glückwunsch an cdu
und grüne das sind die beiden parteien
die zugelegt haben respekt und
komplimente dafür insbesondere auch
richtung grün das eine sensationell
gutes ergebnis für die grünen was aber
auch feststeht ist schwarz-gelb ist
abgewählt worden wir müssen schauen wie
es jetzt eine neue mehrheit hier im
nordrhein westfälischen landtag geben
kann die verlässlich auch die
zukunftsaufgaben lösen kann und da muss
man schon schauen wer spricht jetzt mit
wem wir sind bereit gespräche hier
aufzuführen in nordrhein westfalen um
mitglieder einer fortschritts regierung
auch zu werden darauf kommt jetzt in den
nächsten tagen an und lassen sie uns
jetzt erstmal abwarten welche mehrheiten
oder konstellation überhaupt möglich
sind das liegt ja gerade noch alles sehr
sehr eng beieinander nun erneut die
spitzenkandidatin der grünen die grünen
sind die größten gewinner heute abend
sie haben ihr ergebnis fast verdreifacht
und sind jetzt königsmacher frau
neubauer haben die qual der wahl
zusammen mit cdu oder spd sie werden uns
heute nicht verraten aber was sind die
kriterien nach denen sie entscheiden
werden wir sind im wahlkampf
das grüne eigenständig und selbstbewusst
aufgetreten und wurde offensichtlich
dafür gewählt dass wir gesagt haben wir
brauchen in nordrhein westfalen eine
landesregierung die endlich auf der höhe
der zeit agiert also da wo menschen in
nordrhein westfalen oder die wirtschaft
längst ist und dafür haben wir das
vertrauen bekommen deswegen vielen dank
an die die uns das vertrauen
ausgesprochen
dieser vertrauensvorschuss ist jetzt was
wo wir mit respekt zu arbeiten werden
weiterhin hart arbeiten werden hier in
nordrhein westfalen und für die inhalte
die bedeuten ist es die aufgabe dieser
politischen generation die klimakrise zu
bekämpfen und dabei den lastenausgleich
in der belastung so zu verteilen dass es
fair zugeht in nordrhein-westfalen und
dadurch den zusammenhalt für die
menschen in unserem starken und
vielfältigen land zu gerieren das ist
nicht weniger als das war das was wir im
wahlkampf vertreten haben eigenständig
und das werden wir jetzt in den
kommenden gesprächen mit den
demokratischen parteien auch machen
im stamm von der fdp sie haben ihr
wahlergebnis von 2017 fast halbiert
können sie denn daraus überhaupt einen
auftrag ziehen an irgendeiner
regierungskoalition dann teilzuhaben ich
glaube die frage stellt sich heute abend
gar nicht sondern wir sind in einer
situation wo wir eine ganz schwere
niederlage haben hinnehmen müssen und
das werden wir auch in aller
gründlichkeit
aufarbeiten und der glückwunsch geht
dann die wahl gewinner des heutigen
abends und ansonsten werden wir uns
darauf konzentrieren jetzt zunächst mal
zu analysieren woran es gelegen hat dass
wir nicht in der lage waren unsere
wählerinnen und wähler so zu
mobilisieren wie wir uns das vorgestellt
hat
die auch ihre partei hat verluste erneut
nach chile was heißt dass wir die partei
im westen deutschlands
für uns heißt das zunächst mal dass wir
bei unserem zweiten wahl antritt in
nordrhein westfalen zum zweiten mal in
den landtag eingezogen sind das ist
historisch in der parteiengeschichte
nordrhein westfalen ist noch nie
dagewesen
zum anderen ist es so dass ich gerade
der wahlkampf in den letzten zwei wochen
insbesondere auf das duell cdu/spd
zugespitzt hat darunter leiden kleine
parteien die spd die fdp hat das heute
sehr schmerzlich erwischt die linke
spielt keine rolle mehr wir haben auch
verluste hinnehmen müssen aber wir haben
uns insgesamt konsolidiert wir können
stolz darauf sein zum zweiten mal
hintereinander in den landtag eingezogen
zusammen erfolg für sie herr wüste ist
jetzt daniel günther oder hendrik wüst
für die cdu der größte hoffnungsträger
in der zukunft heute geht zum nordrhein
westfalen wie wir mit respekt und
anstand jetzt mit so einem wahlergebnis
umgehen und auf der anderen seite auch
die weichen stellen die großen fragen
unserer zeit zu beantworten in diesem
industrieland ist die transformation die
größte herausforderung also klimaschutz
und gute arbeitsplätze in der industrie
dauerhaft miteinander zu verbinden das
ist jetzt die aufgabe und darum ging es
schließen wir die runde hier aus
nordrhein westfalen aus düsseldorf
direkt zurück nach mainz vielen dank an
bettina schausten und dort die färber
als bevölkerungsreichstes bundesland hat
die wahl in nrw eine besondere
bundespolitische bedeutung schauen wir
daher jetzt auf die ersten reaktionen
der parteien in der hauptstadt berlin
stärkste kraft heißt für uns
verantwortung zu übernehmen
verantwortung für nordrhein westfalen
verantwortlich verantwortlich zu sein
für eine verlässliche zukunfts regierung
in nordrhein westfalen für die menschen
dort und diese verlässliche regierung
wollen wir dort schmieden natürlich
haben wir für ein besseres ergebnis
gekämpft allerdings hat sich ja die
prozentzahl die wir jetzt bekommen und
mal gucken wie die entwicklung am abend
sind aber sieht danach aus dass wir
zweiter kraft werden und das hat sich ja
angedeutet in den letzten tagen und
gleichwohl muss man ja sagen es steht
noch nichts fest für nordrhein westfalen
außer dass die amtierende
landesregierung die schwarz gelbe
landesregierung abgewählt wurde nach
schleswig-holstein letzte woche haben
wir heute in nordrhein-westfalen unser
historisch bestes ergebnis erzielt das
zeigt dass die menschen wahrnehmen dass
wir antworten auf der höhe der zeit
haben und dass wir bereit sind die
zukunft zu gestalten und es zeigt auch
dass sie uns gerade in nordrhein
westfalen in der regierung sehen wollen
und wollen dass wir dort
regierungsverantwortung übernehmen wir
sind erstmal zufrieden ist aller
voraussicht nach doch reicht das wir
einziehen werden also dafür auch mal
herzlichen dank an unsere wähler wir
haben viele neue gesichter die in den
landtag einziehen werden also es wird
eine alternative hier im landtag geben
das ist wichtig gleichwohl sind wir
natürlich in gänze nicht zufrieden da
werden wir uns die nächsten tage
natürlich auch unterhalten müssen
inwieweit wir hier doch eine initiative
west auch hier brauchen das ist eine
schwere niederlage und das schmerzt
gerade ich glaube alle freie demokraten
aber gerade die freien demokraten und
freidemokrat innen die wie ich auch in
den letzten tagen und wochen sich in
dieser kampagne besonders organisiert
haben engagiert haben und organisiert
haben und da muss man einfach anerkennen
dass das kein guter abend für uns ist
und weitere informationen zur
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen
sowie die berliner runde mit den im
bundestag vertretenen parteien können
sie gleich nach dieser sendung und
zahlen und hintergründe natürlich auch
jederzeit online in der zdf- heute
blicken wir jetzt auf den ukraine krieg
und seine weitreichenden folgen die nato
wird wohl größer finnland hat heute
offiziell beschlossen eine
mitgliedschaft zu beantragen auch
schwedens regierungspartei will einen
beitritt trotz kritischer töne aus der
türkei geht nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg davon aus dass sich der
beitrittsprozess nicht verzögern werde
andreas künast über das treffen der nato
außenminister in und minister in berlin
es kommt darauf an heute auf die
gastgeberin auf jedes wort man sieht der
deutschen außenministerin die gefahr
regelrecht an die plötzlich über dem
berliner gipfel schwebt das ihr
türkischer kollege aus dem großen nato
fest ein großes scheitern macht will und
muss berbalk verhindern schweden und
finnland sind nicht nur unsere partner
nicht nur unsere freunde sondern sie
sind bereits seit langen unsere
europäischen familienmitgliedern das zur
30-köpfigen nato familie zwei neue köpfe
dazu kommen wollen steht seit heute fest
in helsinki iv beschließt die regierung
den beitrittsantrag zu stellen
wir haben heute einen historischen tag
finnland wird seine sicherheit
maximieren
und auch in stockholm spricht sich
ministerpräsidentin andersen vor einer
stunde für die nato-mitgliedschaft aus
dass das bündnis nicht feiert in berlin
dass es kracht wie seit jahren nicht
liegt an der türkei gestern abend gerät
der türkische aussenminister heftig mit
seiner schwedischen amtskollegin
aneinander ihr start sei eine heimstatt
für terroristen
ein türkisches jahr zum beitritt knüpft
cavusoglu an bedingungen die bekämpfung
der pkk ist eine davon ein außenminister
nach dem andern redet auf den türken ein
ergebnis es bleibt schwierig
was die unterschiede zwischen der türkei
schweden und finnland angeht wir haben
gesprochen es gibt weitere gespräche und
eine zuversicht bis es zur abstimmung
kommt muss es konsens geben
in deutschland soll der beitritt nicht
scheitern berbalk kündigt einen
schnellen kabinettsbeschluss und eine
sondersitzung des bundestags an
und nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg
äußerte sich auch zur russischen
invasion der ukraine moskau erreiche
seine ziele nicht die ukraine könne den
krieg gewinnen besonders im osten des
landes dauern die erbitterten kämpfe an
auch um das belagerte stahlwerk in
mariupol alexandra vacano die hölle ist
auf die erde gekommen so der stadtrat
von mario pohl und veröffentlicht dieses
video ein feuerregen über dem azoff
stahlwerk in dem noch ukrainische
soldaten eingekesselt sind die russen
hätten das mit phosphorbomben beschossen
heißt es von ukrainischer seite
unabhängig bestätigen lässt sich das
nicht aber russland spricht inzwischen
von brand auslösen den bomben diese
zivilisten konnten sich auf eigene faust
durchschlagen raus aus mario pohl einen
konvoi von 500 bis 1000 autos mit
geflüchteten ist gestern in sapporo
angekommen nach einer langen odyssee
sicher es war hart die leute haben
vorher schon hatte dinge durchgemacht
sie waren nervös die reise war
verheerend aber das war es wert
erfolge vermeldet kiew rundum hackl die
russen hätten sich zurückgezogen jetzt
sichern hier wieder ukrainische soldaten
die dörfer und die menschen kehren in
ihre völlig zerstörten häuser zurück
weiterhin hart gekämpft wird im don was
im don was ist die lage nach wie vor
sehr schwierig russische truppen
versuchen immer noch zumindest eine art
sieg zu zeigen am achtzigsten tag der
groß angelegten invasion scheint es
besonders verstörend zu sein aber sie
hören nicht auf
und das britische
verteidigungsministerium twittert heute
in seinem lagebericht russland ist es im
vergangenen monat nicht gelungen
nennenswerte gebietsgewinne zu erzielen
russland hat jetzt wahrscheinlich
verluste von einem drittel der
bodenkampf truppe erlitten
trümmer des krieges auch an diesem tag
und lange noch kein frieden in sicht
nach deutschland auch im zweiten quartal
hat die häusliche gewalt erneut
zugenommen die landeskriminalämter
zählten 161.000 opfer ein plus von 1,3
prozent das berichtet die welt am
sonntag zwei drittel der opfer waren
frauen meist ging die gewalt von
partnern oder ex partnern aus die zahlen
könnten noch weit höher liegen denn die
polizei geht von einer hohen
dunkelziffer aus
entsetzen in den usa bei einem offenbar
rassistischen anschlag sind zehn
menschen getötet und drei weitere
verletzt worden die mehrzahl der opfer
war schwarz der 18-jährige weiße täter
hat in der stadt buffalo im bundesstaat
new york in einem supermarkt das feuer
eröffnet er wurde festgenommen und wegen
mordes angeklagt
us präsident biden sprach den opfern und
angehörigen sein mitgefühl aus und sagte
dem inlands tore den kampf an matthiesen
es sind szenen die nach einem
terroranschlag menschen getötet als sie
im supermarkt einkaufen wollten an
diesem nachmittag schrecken leid trauer
über eine tat die amerika erschüttert
weil ein weißer rassist das feuer
eröffnete
er schoss eine frau dann einen priester
wieder eine frau dann ging er rein und
schoss weiter
zehn tote drei weitere menschen wurden
verletzt der schütze hatte
halbautomatische waffen und mengen von
munition als die polizei eintraf ergab
sich der 18-jährige peyton
beschert der schütze ist stundenlang
hierher gefahren um dieses verbrechen an
den menschen von buffalo zu begehen
er stammt aus einem kleinen ort mehr als
300 kilometer entfernt sein ziel wählte
er weil der anteil der schwarzen
bevölkerung in diesem bezirk am größten
ist so schreibt er in seinem
rassistischen antisemitischen hass
pamphlet im internet er glaubt an eine
verschwörungstheorie vom angeblichen
austausch der weißen bevölkerung gegen
andere ethnien die tat trägt alle
merkmale von terrorismus rassistisch und
politisch motiviert die lüge vom
bevölkerungsaustausch wird von
rechtsextremen kommentatoren und
politikern in den usa in europa und auch
in deutschland verbreitet die trauer
vereint die menschen in buffalo und die
erinnerung an die opfer unter ihnen zwei
frauen 86 und 77 jahre alt die sich
besonders um die armen in ihrer stadt
gekümmert habe
im libanon haben die menschen heute ein
neues parlament gewählt mitten in der
wohl schwersten krise des landes kaum
jobs immens steigende preise und auch
die folgen der explosionskatastrophe im
hafen von beirut vor knapp zwei jahren
hat das land nicht überwunden viele
libanesen setzen deshalb eigentlich auf
einen wechsel dennoch rechnen
beobachterinnen und beobachter damit
dass die von iran gestützte hisbollah
partei erneut stärkste kraft werden
könnte einerseits gilt die opposition
als schlecht organisiert andererseits
sollen stimmen gekauft worden seien
eine knallbunte party mit schrägen
outfits und vielen emotionen das ist der
eurovision songcontest und politisch
soll der esc sein so die vorgabe aber an
diesem jahr kam es anders denn gewonnen
hat die ukraine mit dem kammerorchester
nie zuvor hat ein ex so viele punkte von
den zuschauenden bekommen die klare
botschaft europa steht zusammen über ein
abend mit schrillen auftritten großen
stimme und noch mehr symbolik berichtet
annette hilsenbeck
wird diese chips der wunsch nach frieden
es ist ein ungewöhnlicher anfang der
zeigt dieser eurovision song contest es
anders es geht nicht nur um musik
[Applaus]
das überwältigende votum der zuschauer
lief dann die band carlos orchestra zu
musik zwölf punkte aus fast jedem land
höchstwerte als zeichen für frieden und
demokratie für den song stéphanie
[Applaus]
vorsprung nicht der mutter des sängers
gewidmet empfinden ukraine den song
inzwischen als hymne auf ihre heimat der
musikalische triumph für sie wichtig
vielen dank danke dass er die ukraine
unterstützt dieser sich es für jeden
ukraine der ukraine
der erste in diesem jahr hoch politische
statements auf der bühne sind laut
regelwerk nicht erlaubt und werden dort
geduldet fans um die musiker der anderen
länder zeigen ihre solidarität in blau
gelb
hinter dem carlos orchestra konnten sich
großbritannien und spanien platzieren
deutschland landete mit malic harris auf
dem letzten platz
die ukraine aber ist gewinner des esc
dazu veröffentlichte der ukrainische
präsident jens g ein post in sozialen
medien
unser mut beeindruckt die welt unserer
musik erobert europa im nächsten jahr
empfängt die ukraine den eurovision
die mitglieder von carlos orchestra
müssen in zwei tagen nach hause den
musikalischen knvb nehmen sie mit um die
solidarität europa
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommen wir zum sport mit
norbert norbert gestern super spannung
in der ersten bundesliga jetzt den
fußball kaminer zweiten ja das ganze so
laut sagen schalke stand ja bereits als
aufsteiger fest aber wer begleitet
königsblau direkt in liga eins bremen
darmstadt und hamburg hatten die chance
genutzt hat sie werde marvin duksch traf
in der 51 minute zum 2 0-endstand im
heimspiel gegen regensburg bremen
verteilt wird damit tabellenplatz zwei
direkter wiederaufstieg von werder in
die bundesliga ja und dann der hsv
mittel kaufmanns schoss die hamburger in
der 85 minute in rostock zum 3 2 sieg
dank des besseren torverhältnisses
schaffte es der hsv so auf den
relegationsplatz trauer statt dessen in
darmstadt trotz des 13 0 heimsiegs der
lilien gegen paderborn blieb am ende nur
der undankbare vierte platz darmstadt
zwar punktgleich mit dem hsv aber im mit
dem schlechteren torverhältnis und dann
schauen wir jetzt mal wie in bremen
dieser sieg gefeiert wurde
statt musikern in grün-weiß nicht
gegeizt mit euphorie wird heute bei den
hanseaten
wiederaufstieg nach nur einem jahr
zweite liga
wir sind wieder in der ersten bundesliga
bremen muss erstklassig ja meister
werden wer sonst wenn nicht wir auf
jeden fall mit ole werner schaffen wir
das große träume in bremen große
erleichterung in hamburg der hsv kann
noch aufsteigen
ich hoffe wir geben nicht auf und wir
bieten das noch das eine oder andere
spiel haben wir auch noch gelobt als
astro fun immer wieder hoffnung ist egal
wir steigen jetzt
treffen sie auf die hsv ohne felix
magath der in der relegation versucht
hertha in der liga zu halten in hamburg
heißt es zuversicht handeln
ja noch ein trainer abgang in der
bundesliga zum saisonende wolfsburg
coach florian coesfeld verlässt den vfl
nach nur sieben monaten tätigkeit im
verein
und wer hat heute neben bremen und
hamburg auch noch was zu feiern ja der
fc bayern über 10.000 fans bejubelten
auf den münchner marienplatz ihren
deutschen meister der zum zehnten mal in
folge die schale gewinnen konnte und sie
skandierten in sprechchören lieber bleib
lieber bleibt an die adresse von
stürmerstar robert lewandowski der
möglicherweise schon zur nächsten saison
den fcb verlassen hat
ja und er hat auch was zu feiern jürgen
klopp und sein fc liverpool haben den
englischen fa-cup gewonnen nach torlosen
120 minuten im pokalfinale gegen chelsea
fiel die entscheidung im
elfmeterschießen
liverpools torwart ellison becker
pariert den schuss von chelsea stürmer
mason mount direkt danach der
siegtreffer für die red zum 6 5 durch
constantinos ziemlich katze
und erstmals was zu feiern hatte die
deutsche eishockey mannschaft gestern
abend bei der wm in finnland nach der
auftaktniederlage gegen weltmeister
kanada ein überraschender sieg gegen die
slowakei leo kördel erzielt den treffer
zur 2 0 führung für deutschland
nach der anschlusstreffer von christian
pospischil dank des starken torwarts
philipp grubauer blieb es am ende beim
deutschen 2 1-erfolg und morgen an das
dritte deutsche gruppenspiel gegen
frankreich danke nachweise werden wir
noch einen kurzen blick aufs wetter
morgen ist es östlich der weser und in
ostbayern freundlich sonst ziehen von
westen schauer und gewitter auf ist
drohen unwetter mit starkregen die
temperatur erreicht 20 bis 28 an der
ostsee 17 grad
um die landtagswahl in nrw geht es
natürlich auch um 21 45 im heute journal
mit marietta slomka und mit unserer
sondersendung zur wahl machen wir jetzt
auch direkt weiter ich übergebe an
bettina schausten
ja ganz vielen dank iana und willkommen
zurück im zdf wahlstudio in düsseldorf
wir haben noch mal ein paar minuten
kompakte information für sie natürlich
dann auch als vorlauf zur berliner runde
die sicherlich heute abend viel zu
diskutieren hat und spannend werden
dürfte wir beginnen natürlich wie immer
mit einer hochrechnung denn es gibt ja
noch verschiebungen und es ist auch noch
nicht alles klar matthias so sieht's
auch und aus und deshalb gucken wir auf
die neue hochrechnung 1925 die cdu käme
auf 35 4 prozent spd 27,2 fdp 5,5 afd
5,5 beide demnach knapp drin da geht es
jeweils noch ein kleines fragezeichen ob
sie es wirklich schaffen aber dieses
fragezeichen wird mit jeder hochrechnung
etwas kleiner die grünen 18,2 die linke
nicht im landtag vertreten weiterhin
nicht 2,1 jetzt gucken wir auf die
gewinne und verluste ist hat sich
wahnsinnig viel bewegt im vergleich zur
letzten landtagswahl die cdu von einem
starken ergebnis kommen gewinnen noch
mal dazu die spd von ihrem schlechtesten
ergebnis kommt verliert nochmal recht
deutlich die fdp mit sehr großen
verlusten minus 7,1 punkte die fdp
verliert auch 1,9 und die grünen sind
was die zugewinne betrifft der große
sieger des abends 11,8 punkte zu
gewinnen die linke verliert 2,8 punkte
schauen wir auf die sitzverteilung hier
im düsseldorfer landtag bei angenommenen
199 sitzen käme die cdu auf 77 die spd
auf neun und fünf sich fdp auf 12 usd
auf 12 und die grünen auf 39 und wir
gucken mal was das heißt für mögliche
koalitionen
die senkrechte linie bezeichnet die
absolute mehr hat jemand braucht zum
regieren 100 stimmen sind dass cdu und
fdp die bisherige regiert haben kommen
nur auf 89 das reicht also deutlich
nicht damit ist diese regierung
abgewählt cdu und grüne schwarz grün 116
das reicht deutlich spd und grüne 98
sitze da fehlen mittlerweile hat also
sogar schon zwei sitze zu den 100 die
man braucht und spd/grüne mit der fdp
das würde wiederum sehr klar reichen
dankeschön materials also das ist die
ausgangslage die spd wollte hier
stärkste kraft werden das hat nicht
geklappt sie hat im gegenteil verloren
die cdu ist hier der wahlgewinner aber
der spitzenkandidat kutschaty
beansprucht durchaus hier eine regierung
bilden zu wollen und darüber habe ich
vor ein paar minuten hier bei uns im
wald studio mit ihm gesprochen und der
spd herausforderer thomas kutschaty ist
ja zu uns gekommen schöne namen tecwatch
archivgut macht so das ist das
schlechteste ergebnis für die spd was je
nordrhein-westfalen eingefahren wurde
gleichwohl geben sie sich noch ganz
selbstbewusst glauben sie denn noch dass
sie hier eine regierung zustande kommen
bekommen können du liegst das ergebnis
nicht das was wir uns gewünscht haben
wir sind von vor einem jahr von 17
prozent in umfragen natürlich deutlich
hoch gegangen aber unser ziel war es
natürlich stärkste partei zu werden das
ist nicht gelungen gleichwohl steht auch
fest schwarz gelb ist abgewählt hier in
nordrhein westfalen und es muss eine
neue regierungsmehrheit gebildet werden
hier nordrhein westfalen im augenblick
liegen die parteien ja auch gerade die
kleinen ja noch ganz knapp auch zusammen
und man weiß noch nicht welche sitz von
zahlungen im nächsten landtag
stattfinden wird und deswegen müssen
alle demokratischen parteien jetzt in
den nächsten tagen miteinander gespräche
führen um zu schauen wie kann eine
regierung gebildet werden die diese land
nach vorne bringt fortschritt bringt und
mehr bildung und mehr gerechtigkeit
organisiert für rot grün reicht es im
moment nicht da müssten sie die fdp dazu
nehmen die aber hier am meisten verloren
hat
stark zurückgegangen ist wäre das denn
ein politisches signal
da warten wir doch erst mal ab wie jetzt
tatsächlich die sitzverteilung im
nordrhein westfälischen landtag ist das
ist jetzt gerade die frage ein
sinnvoller einsatz unter welchem er
heizmöglichkeiten dann tatsächlich sind
wenn wir das ergebnis haben dann werden
wir uns auch unter den demokratischen
parteien unterhalten welche
regierungskoalition ist denn machbar und
denkbar und gut für die menschen die in
not habe der bundeskanzler olaf scholz
hat sie hier stark unterstützt in
nordrhein-westfalen hätten sich sich
doch ein bisschen mehr scholz effekt
davon erhofft wir haben ja viel
rückendeckung bekommen und sagte ja
gerade schon vor einem jahr waren wir
hier bei 17 prozent in nordrhein
westfalen
da hat keiner mit gerechnet dass wir
überhaupt mal wieder in die situation
kommen dass wir hier eine regierung
bilden können in nordrhein westfalen das
ist jetzt eingetreten dass das machbar
und möglich ist und das hat natürlich
eine ganze menge auch damit zu tun dass
die spd die bundestagswahl gewonnen hat
und dass olaf scholz kanzler ist das hat
uns gesagt natürlich rückenwind gegeben
also sie müssten hier eine ampel bilden
aber die ampel hat durch diesen durch
dieses wahlergebnis eigentlich er
sozusagen den tritt vors knie bekommt
sehen sie das anders noch ist nicht
sicher ob es eine ampel sein muss oder
ob es für rote grüne tatsächlich auch
ausreichend wäre aber natürlich müssen
alle parteien sich jetzt gedanken machen
auch bei der fdp ist das jetzt natürlich
ein schwieriger prozess
die heute sehr sehr viel verloren haben
ihren stand habe ich ein sehr fairen
wahlkampf viele gemeinsame
diskussionsveranstaltungen auch geführt
insofern kann ich ein wenig
nachvollziehen wie das jetzt auch für
die fdp natürlich eine große
herausforderung ist die auch natürlich
schauen muss welche rolle möchte sie
zukünftig einnehmen aber lassen sie uns
doch erstmal die gespräche dann führen
wenn wir das ergebnis auch genau wissen
sagt thomas kutschaty danke fürs kommen
so große gewinner des heutigen abends
mit fast zwölf prozentpunkten plus im
vergleich zum letzten mal sind die
grünen und wir hören hier nochmal die
spitzenkandidatin mona neubauer
und unsere hände bahn zum mord dann
westphal
vor zwei jahren angefangen jeden tag zu
leben in den kommunen mit landesweit 20
prozent mit ehrenamtlichen grünen die
jeden tag die probleme im status quo
lösen für die menschen in diesen städten
und gemeinden darüber haben wir
vertrauen gewonnen ich danke allen in
der steuerungsgruppe ich danke dem
landesvorstand ich danke den
abgeordneten lassen landtag ich danke
natürlich unseren vertreterin vertretern
in berlin in europa aber vor allem wird
es mir nach ich bin halt auch noch
parteivorsitzenden alle setzen 20.000
mitglieder dieses landesverbandes
ja noch verschlafen
gehandelt gearbeitet
jetzt liegt es an uns das als
vertrauensvorschuss voller respekt im
hakel zu übersetzen vielen dank
ja in handeln übersetzen das ist die
frage unter einem ministerpräsidenten
der cdu oder der spd beide wollen
gespräche mit den grünen führen so ist
jedenfalls die ansage heute abend und
schon im wahlkampf hatte hendrik wüst
der
cdu-ministerpräsident der heute hier
klar vorn liegt sein herz für die grünen
durchaus entwickelt also die cdu feiert
hier heute abend ihren wahlerfolg wie es
so ganz richtig weiter geht weiß man
noch nicht aber wir hören mal hendrik
ist ein ganz herzlicher dank gilt an die
fdp wir haben in den letzten jahren
unser land gut regiert und gut
vorangebracht und wir haben das in einem
freundschaftlichen verhältnissen fall
einen freundschaftlichen und
verlässlichen verhältnis getan und wir
waren immer verlässlich an den
interessen der menschen in diesem land
orientiert
[Applaus]
ich werde jetzt auch die demokratischen
parteien zugehen und ich werde alles
dafür tun dass unser land gut durch
dieses schwierige zeit kommt und
verlässlich regiert werd ich bin der
festen überzeugung unser land wird die
herausforderungen der zukunft mit all
seinen stärken meistern viel herzlichen
dank dass ihr alle hier seid und viel
spaß
so hendrik wüst bedankt sich auch noch
mal bei der fdp aber es ist so schwarz
gelb die landesregierung
nordrhein-westfalen ist abgewählt wegen
der schwäche der fdp und deshalb schauen
wir jetzt mal nach berlin wo sich der
fdp-bundesvorsitzende christian lindner
der beim letzten mal hier der
spitzenkandidat war und ein
rekordergebnis eingefahren hatte lange
zeit gelassen hat heute abend um diese
niederlage zu kommentieren ihr aber
jetzt das statement
heutigen abend hat der ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst einen überzeugenden
wahlerfolg erzielt und dafür gebührt ihm
unser respekt und auch unsere
gratulation
natürlich hätten wir uns gewünscht dass
auch die freien demokraten von diesen
guten regierungshandeln im größten
bundesland profitiert hätten das ist
nicht der fall wir haben heute nicht
davon profitiert dass für fünf jahre
auch die richtung des landes mitgeprägt
haben wir haben eine man muss es so
sagen desaströse niederlage heute abend
zu verzeichnen wir haben jetzt
abgewartet als präsidium auf die jüngste
hochrechnung der ard um letzte klarheit
zu gewinnen in welche richtung es geht
aber dennoch kann uns ein solches
ergebnis in unserer betrachtung nicht
beruhigen es ist für uns ein sehr
trauriger abend und ich sage das ganz
persönlich nach denen ich 2012 und auch
2017 als spitzenkandidat die fdp in den
landtagswahlkampf und in den landtag
führen dürfte denke ich natürlich heute
insbesondere an die kolleginnen und
kollegen in düsseldorf ihnen möchte ich
sagen kopf hoch freie demokraten
gewinnen zusammen freier demokraten
verlieren auch zusammen
der
fdp-bundesvorsitzende christian lindner
der die idee noch mal anspricht weil
dort die fdp mit fünf prozent
ausgewiesen war in der prognose also
sehr wackelig die forschungsgruppe
wahlen sah sie und zieht sie auch jetzt
bei 5,5 prozent das würde dann reichen
wenn auch deutlich und stark gestutzt im
landtag zu bleiben so was macht man mit
dieser ausgangslage man fragt doch noch
mal die wähler und das haben wir auch
vorher schon gemacht was würden die sich
denn hier in nordrhein westfalen
wünschen welche regierung das schauen
wir uns jetzt an bettina in der ersten
grafik und da sehen wir dass rot-grün
mit relativ deutlichem abstand gut
gefunden wird alle anderen bündnisse
werden mehrheitlich er abgelegt und
jetzt gucken wir mal wichtig ist ja auch
was sagen denn die anhänger der grünen
und da sehen wir ein noch deutlicheres
bild 79 prozent der grünen anhänger
fänden rot grün gut 55 prozent nur
schwarz grün und die ampel 49 also man
kann sagen die koalition die deutlich am
meisten präferiert wird oder gewollt
wird die hat wahrscheinlich keine mehr
als dankeschön matthias und da können
wir jetzt noch mal ganz unprätentiös
aber sehr direkt stimmenfang von unserer
reporterin denn pakistan die genau die
gleiche frage jetzt heute abend hier in
düsseldorf gestellt hat
wir sind unterwegs am rheinufer und
haben hier gerade familie hubert
kennengelernt familie hubert wollte live
mit dabei sein wenn hier in düsseldorf
gewählt wird und das ergebnis miterleben
herr hubert welche
regierungskonstellation wäre aus ihrer
sicht die beste für nrw aus meiner sicht
schwarz grün warum haben den auftrag der
wähler bekommen haben die meisten
stimmen bekommen und die ziele die beide
parteien verfolgen decken sich mit
meinem forderungen und wünschen an das
land und was sind so jetzt die
drängendsten themen was müsste
eigentlich direkt ab morgen hier im land
angegangen werden
ich würde auf jeden fall sagen
wirtschaft mit umwelt weiterhin effektiv
verbinden und ja endlich mal richtig die
umweltprobleme angehen vielen herzlichen
dank familie hubert genießen sie den
abend noch in düsseldorf damit zurück
ins studio
dankeschön länder so viel für den moment
wir geben jetzt weiter an theo koll der
in berlin seine runde versammelt hat um
die bundespolitischen auswirkungen aus
diesem wahlergebnis nun zu diskutieren
wir sind sehr gespannt der und melden
uns dann hier in einer guten halben
stunde wieder zurück also ab nach berlin
vielen dank und herzlich willkommen zur
berliner runde es ist nicht nur die
wichtigste wahl des jahres sie sagt auch
einiges aus über die lage der partei im
bund denn die wahl war er weniger als
vorherige geprägt durch alles
überstrahlende persönlichkeiten nrw das
ist die kleine bundesrepublik und damit
sagt uns die wahl etwas über den scholz
und auch den märz faktor über das sich
verändernde machtgefüge in der
ampelkoalition über die todeszone der
linkspartei und vieles mehr das wollen
wir in kompakten 30 minuten ausloten und
zwar traditionell mit den
generalsekretären und
geschäftsführerinnen der im bundestag
vertretenen parteien
wir begrüßen
emily büning politische
geschäftsführerin der grünen bernd
baumann erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer der afd mario czaja
generalsekretär der cdu
bijan djir sarai
generalsekretär der fdp
martin huber generalsekretär der csu
kevin kühnert generalsekretär der spd
und jörg schindler
bundesgeschäftsführer der linken
hat ja ja die cdu liegt mit großem
abstand vorn ausreichend für den
unbedingten regierungsanspruch wir haben
klaren regierungsauftrag erhalten um
eine verlässliche regierung für die
zukunft zu bilden um die wesentlichen
herausforderungen dieses landes nach
vorne zu bringen insbesondere wirtschaft
und umwelt politik zusammenzubringen das
ist ja auch im einspieler genannt worden
das sind die großen herausforderungen
dieses landes hendrik wüst hat ein
fantastisches ergebnis erzielt aber auch
herzlichen glückwunsch an die grünen die
auch wahlgewinner dieses sie brauchen ja
die grünen für eine koalition wie wollen
sie denn um die grünen werben nehmen wir
das beispiel der abstand die 1000 meter
abstandsregel zwischen wohnhäusern und
windkraftanlagen können sie die mit dem
segen der parteizentrale kippen also
unsere aufgabe ist nicht von dieser
stelle die verhandlungen zu führen das
wird hendrik wüst sehr
verantwortungsbewusst mit der cdu in
nordrhein-westfalen tun entscheidend ist
dass es eine verlässliche koalition ist
wir haben gut zusammengearbeitet mit der
fdp verlässliche regierung in der zeit
gehabt es ist ein bedauerliches ergebnis
was uns auch schmerzt weil wir eine gute
zusammenarbeit hatten wir können das
nachvollziehen aber jetzt gibt es einen
anderen regierungsauftrag es gibt zwei
eindeutige wahl gewinner dieses abends
und wir wollen eine gemeinsame
verlässlich regierung bilden und also
die themen liegen auf der hand und vor
ort wird man für alles eine lösung für
das werben muss also in düsseldorf
passieren kann hat ihr kandidat hat im
wahlkampf massiv auf olaf scholz gesetzt
war plakatiert gemeinsam für nordrhein
westfalen und deutschland hat man auch
jetzt gemeinsam verloren oder hertie
nein also ergebnisse holen wir gemeinsam
völlig egal wie sie ausfallen aber dass
das eine klare niederlage ist das mögen
manche so sehen ich möchte dem
widersprechen an dieser stelle die spd
hat nicht alle ihre wahlziele erreicht
wir sind nicht stärkste kraft geworden
wir hätten auch gerne ein paar prozente
mehr geholt andere sind stärkste kraft
geworden die cdu es zu gratulieren zu
ihrem guten ergebnis aber ihre bisherige
koalition die cdu nicht mehr halten
können heute abgewählt worden es ist ein
wahlziel auch der spd gewesen und
demokratie ist manchmal ein bisschen
komplizierter verschiedene parteien
haben gegebenenfalls am heutigen abend
und darüber hinaus die möglichkeit eine
regierung zu bilden und darüber kann und
sollte man dann auch gespräche mit der
bahn stand von 7 prozent hinter dem
erstplatzierten schauen sie in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik hat es so
viele beispiele gegeben von politischen
karrieren von menschen die nur deshalb
mal zum zuge gekommen sind weil sie als
zweiter im regierungsbündnisse gegangen
und sie sind und sie angeführt haben
willy brandt ist so jemand gewesen 1969
ole von beust ist gleichzeitig der
anderen orte sind ja und lassen sie mich
da gerne eine grundsätzliche bemerkungen
machen ich glaube in dieser bunter und
vielfältiger werdenden demokratie wir
sehen wie viele wir hier in der runde
sind als vertreter der parteien im
bundestag müssen wir alle auch die spd
sich daran gewöhnen dass wahlergebnisse
nicht mehr so einfach handelbar sind wie
sieht es in den gemütlichen
entschuldigung 70er und 80er jahren
parteipolitisch noch gewesen sind es
sind am wahlabend nicht immer schon alle
fragen beantwortet und so wie ich heute
sage auch eine partei die nur zwei
stärkste kraft geworden ist kann
gegebenenfalls eine regierung führen so
würde ich das auch bei einer wahl wo wir
stärkste kraft geworden sind auch
anderen parteien zu sprechen
jury und die war so vielfach umworbene
ist das für sie vorstellbar eine
koalition mit einem partner der so
deutlich auf dem zweiten platz vom
wähler
gelandet ist also wir freuen uns vor
allen dingen dass wir nach schleswig
holstein jetzt auch diese woche und
historisch bestes ergebnis geholt haben
in dieser landtagswahl in nordrhein
westfalen
das haben wir geschafft das damit dass
wir einen wahlkampf für inhalte gemacht
haben wir sind angetreten um nordrhein
westfalen da den stillstand zu beenden
um einen politikwechsel mit uns grünen
herbeizuführen wir haben forderungen
aufgestellt wie das wir nordrhein
westfalen zur ersten klimaneutralen
industrieregionen das heißt sie wollen
sie die eu das nicht erfüllt dann sind
sie bei der spd wir werden jetzt
gespräche führen in den nächsten tagen
und ausloten welche für welche mehrheit
für welche koalition wie in welcher
koalition wir die meisten grünen inhalte
umsetzen können das ist für uns oberste
priorität wir wurden gewählt wir haben
einen sehr klaren auftrag von den
wählerinnen und will dann gekriegt dass
wir das bundesland nrw auf die höhe der
zeit bringen die wählerinnen und wähler
haben gesagt wir haben die antworten auf
die drängendsten fragen der zeit wir
machen seit jahren
politik dafür
dieses land nach vorne zu bringen das
tun wir gerade im bund in der koalition
an der ampel und wäre meine nächste
frage das heißt wenn sie jetzt diesen
klaren wählerauftrag
haben was heißt denn das für ihr ihre
position ihren einfluss in der ampel
oder leisten sie da verzichten sie mehr
einfluss nein ich denke in der
bundesregierung sind wir aktuell in
einem sehr konstruktiven verhältnis wir
haben wir arbeiten gut zusammen in der
ampel mit spd und fdp wir sehen in nrw
dass wir jetzt den auftrag haben da eine
koalition auszuloten das können wir uns
sowohl mit der cdu als auch mit spd und
fdp vorstellen je nachdem wo wir die
grünen inhalte umsetzen und ich glaube
im kabinett gibt es wichtigere dinge zu
besprechen als die landtagswahlen in nrw
sondern da haben wir drängende themen
mit den fragen der auswirkungen des
ukraine krieges schießerei ihr
parteivorsitzender hat gerade gesagt
desaströses ergebnis
die liberalen haben ja im
koalitionsvertrag relativ viel gewonnen
in anführungsstrichen auch in einigen
wichtigen
regierungsentscheidungen aber sie
verlieren die wähler erklären sie uns
das also zunächst einmal es ist ein
trauriger abend aus der sicht der fdp
ich habe mir das mit sicherheit anders
vorgestellt wie sie wissen komme ich
selbst auf nordrhein-westfalen und man
kann dieses ergebnis heute abend nicht
schön reden wir werden daher in den
nächsten
tagen sehr intensiv in nordrhein
westfalen in den gremien darüber
sprechen das ist nicht was schief
gelaufen also sie hatten ja jetzt eine
serie von landtagswahlen und sie als
generalsekretär haben sich ja sicher da
schon mit beschäftigt zunächst einmal
das ist ja sie sagen ja selbst essent
landtagswahlen es sind landespolitische
themen die dominieren
die dominieren wir müssen ehrlich
analysen durchführen und die werden wir
auch machen in düsseldorf in nordrhein
das war also 40 prozent der wähler sagen
es war ein bundesteam auch in
nordrhein-westfalen und sie haben noch
keine antwort schauen sie mal wenn sie
sich wenn sie wenn sie unbedingt über
die bundesebene reden wollen gerne wenn
sie sich die aktuellen umfragewerte der
bundes-fdp anschauen die sind zwischen
acht und zehn prozent das ist ein riesen
unterschied zu dem ergebnis dass wie in
nordrhein westfalen gesehen haben
offensichtlich wird sehr genau geschaut
was ist landespolitik und was das
bundespolitik und das haben wir heute
abend gesehen und in mehreren ländern
christian lindner ist ja mit dem
versprechen von finanzieller solidität
angetreten und steht natürlich jetzt
auch erzwungenermaßen für eine
gigantische neuverschuldung könnte das
ein grund sein nein definitiv nicht
zunächst einmal christian lindner war
heute abend kein kandidat in nordrhein
westfalen das war eher 2017 das war er
2012 aber heute abend war er nicht oder
bei dieser landtagswahl war er nicht
spitzenkandidat und das was sie als
thema angesprochen haben die
finanzpolitische entwicklung das sind
die folgen eines oder gewaltige
veränderung die wir derzeit in
deutschland und europa erleben wir haben
krieg in europa und dementsprechend
bedeutet das dass viele dinge die wir
übrigens auch im koalitionsvertrag war
zu dem zeitpunkt hat man uns nicht
vorstellen können dass wir in europa
oder in deutschland diese entwicklung
haben werden viele dinge haben sich noch
mal anders entwickelt und das bedeutet
gute politik bedeutet dass man diese
rahmenbedingungen immer berücksichtigen
muss er doch mal die afg hat jetzt
mittlerweile ich habe schon mal
nachgeschaut neuen landtagswahl an den
folge verloren welche lehren zieht denn
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer
daraus also das war jetzt eine sehr
schwierige wahl das hat sich alles
fokussiert auf die beiden
spitzenkandidaten das war kopf an kopf
sodass die der eine oder andere
konservative sich gesagt hat er wenig
liebe jetzt noch mal die cdu mit
zusammengebissenen zähnen bevor es zu
links grün kommt dazu kommt in nrw ich
war selber 30 jahre bochumer mit der
westdeutschen allgemeinen zeitung und
dem wdr ist der afg gegenüber sozusagen
neutraler objektiver journalismus kaum
möglich wir sind mehr oder weniger
totgeschwiegen worden deswegen muss ich
mich noch mal ganz deutlich bei den
wahlkämpfern bedanken nordrhein zahlen
die das auf den straßen und plätzen
wirklich mit werbung mit wut mit motor
angetrieben haben und wir reden
natürlich wir haben etwas verloren wir
hatten uns vorstellen können gerade weil
der viele themen brennen das ist eine
ganze stadtteile wo die kriminalität
explodiert wir haben steigende
energiepreise die auch auf die falsche
energiepolitik zurückzuführen sind wir
haben steigende inflation inflation die
auch auf die falsche ezb politik
zurückzuführen ist darf ich in einen
abgeordneten ihrer fraktion zieht hier
norbert kleinwächter der fordert für die
bundesspitze zitat dringend neue köpfe
mit sicherem auftreten und neuen ideen
hat er recht fehlt es an der fdp spitze
in neuen köpfen und neuen ideen wir sind
eine partei wo kontrovers diskutiert
wird auch um köpfe und solche
einlassungen finden sie in allen
parteien und fraktionen dass sie
überhaupt überhaupt kein thema wir gehen
diese in diese in diesen
in diese sozusagen wahl des vorstandes
rein und da wird sich sät wird sich
zeigen was sagen sozusagen sich dann
herausstellt wir sind doch stabil wir
sind auch jetzt im größten bundesland
wieder sicher drin die fdp ich habe ja
gerade gesagt die kleinen kommen etwas
unter die räder zwei drittel der wähler
verloren das ist dramatisch die linke
ist gar nicht mehr drin also wir sind
schon relativ solide stehen wir in der
politischen landschaft und angesichts
der medienlandschaft muss ich sagen
haben wir da gut gekämpft es klingt wie
ein vertrauter vorwurf herr schindler
gleich man muss sagen bleiben wir bei
den verlierern es ist die dritte wahl
des jahres und dritte landesparlament in
dem ihre partei nicht mehr vertreten
sein wird saarland 2,6 prozent schleswig
holstein 1,7 dazu der rücktritt einer
parteivorsitzenden und vorwürfe
sexueller übergriffe ist ihre partei
politisch schwer verletzt oder ist es
noch schlimmer na ja sie haben sie
angesprochen wir zahlen gerade das
ergebnis ab was in den letzten jahren an
selbstbeschäftigung an streit an
innerparteilichen
unannehmlichkeiten bei uns aufgelaufen
ist so da ist die nordrhein westfalen
war sie haben es angesprochen durchaus
auch ein teil davon das gibt es
überhaupt nicht anders als so gut zu
beschreiben aber die frage ist ja wie
kommen wir dabei raus und wie kommen wir
wieder zu dem was uns als linke ausmacht
wie können wir vertrauen zurückgewinnen
bei wählerinnen und wählern und da sind
jetzt dabei bundesparteitag findet jetzt
im juni statt dort soll es auch
klärungen geben das ist völlig klar und
das müssen wir auch tun wir haben uns
einfach in der vergangenheit sehr vielen
eindeutigkeiten geleistet und wenn es
jetzt darum geht zum beispiel nordrhein
westfalen die verkehrswende
voranzutreiben wenn es darum geht aber
auch auf bundespolitischer ebene die
energiepolitik zu verändern wenn es
darum geht die sozialpolitik zu
verändern dann wollen wir vorschläge
machen zum beispiel auf landesebene ich
kann mich endlich mal selber in
nordrhein-westfalen student und ich habe
dort das semesterticket genutzt aber
eben nur als studierender das war von
aachen bis bielefeld warum kann das
nicht jetzt 20 jahre fast später warum
kann das nicht für alle bürgerinnen und
bürger nordrhein-westfalens gelten oder
nehmen wir bundes parteien
bundespolitisch wenn es darum geht
einmalzahlungen von 100 oder 200 euro
jetzt auszusprechen aber die inflation
von 7,4 prozent ist ja nicht nur ein mal
im monat sie ist ja jedem ohne deswegen
brauchen wir
kontinuierliche erhöhung der löhne und
auch der sozialleistungen hat damit die
leute nicht fahren wenn ich habe es mal
ausgerechnet 33 euro alleine für ein
hartz iv empfänger weniger dadurch dass
7,4 prozent inflation ist und zwar trotz
der regelsatzerhöhung das ist ein
skandal und ich will da müssen wir als
linke halt deutlich besser werden das zu
thematisieren
herr hubert der neue in diesem kreis
herzlich willkommen bayern sie standen
ja in nordrhein westfalen nicht zur wahl
als csu naturgemäß
bayern weltweiten kommenden jahr aktuell
sind 53 prozent ihrer landsleute
unzufrieden mit dem ministerpräsidenten
was kann was sollte denn markus söder
von den aktuellen wahlgewinnern lernen
herrn wüst oder an günter es kam auch
vor kurzem eine umfrage nach der 58
prozent der bayern sehr zufrieden sind
mit markus söder und die csu bei 38
prozent steht glaube das ist auch eine
gute weg markt die wir auch jedoch
betonen müssten und ansonsten heißt das
ergebnis heute dass markus söder und
hendrik wüst in zukunft gemeinsam
weiterarbeiten können denen der klaren
regierungsauftrag heute liegt natürlich
bei der cdu und hendrik wüst und ich bin
schon überrascht mit welcher
selbstverständlichkeit die spd ausgehend
von ihrem schlechtesten historisch
schlechtesten ergebnis einen auftrag
ableitet die regierung zu bilden und
noch dazu über sieben prozent
unterschied zur cdu sie haben ja als
partei und wird der ministerpräsident
eine besondere beziehung zum land
nordrhein westfalen
wenn man schaut auf das verhältnis zum
vorherigen ministerpräsidenten laschet
dem sie das leben ja durchaus nicht so
leicht gemacht haben kann sich die cdu
jetzt auf leisere töne einstellen ich
erinnere ein zitat von markus söder der
sagte er will jetzt künftig der
landespartei sein markus söder hat
hendrik wüst kannte massiv unterstützt
mit gemeinsamen terminen in köln in olpe
es gerade eine gemeinsame
präsidiumssitzung von cdu und csu und
markus söder hat auch deutlich gemacht
wie sehr sich wünscht dass hendrik wüst
weiterhin ministerpräsident bleibt und
das ergebnis heute geht er genau in
diese richtung jetzt schauen wir auf den
starken mann ihrer partei in nordrhein
westfalen
naturgemäß gilt ja der ministerpräsident
in nordrhein westfalen als kandidat für
höhere weihen sie wissen was ich sagen
will
er ist 20 jahre jünger als der jetzige
cdu vorsitzende daniel günther immerhin
18 jahre sind die beiden mit blick auf
so etwas langfristiges wie
kanzlerkandidatur dann auf augenhöhe
jetzt mit dem cdu vorsitzenden
wir sind froh dass wir starke
ministerpräsidenten haben und damit auch
ein breites angebot an persönlichkeiten
die verantwortung tragen können frauen
und männer ministerinnen und minister
und es ist aber auch ein wesentlicher
erfolg sie haben die bundespolitischen
implikation angesprochen dass wir unter
der führung von friedrich merz jetzt
einen starken gemeinsamen auftritt haben
dass unsere themen im mittelpunkt stehen
das wir für eine starke wirtschaft für
gute job also nummer eins standen haben
friedrich merz hat dieses team
zusammengeführt er hat im wahlkampf
stark mitgeholfen und friedrich merz ist
der mann der die union geeint hat und
der die breiten flügel auch
zusammengebracht hat er ist der starke
mann der union er zweifelsohne
klare ansage also dass die beiden
jüngeren sich da noch gedulden dürfen
herr köhler das ampelbündnis ist ja mit
den willen angetreten vieles anders zu
machen auch im umgang miteinander und
haben wir diese woche erlebt dass
fdp-abgeordnete eine sitzung des
verteidigungsausschusses
verlassen haben
genervt weil der kanzler innen nicht
antworten würde anton hofreiter lässt
sich zitieren das problem ist dem
kanzleramt der kanzler kommuniziert der
jetzt sehr viel mehr als als vorher aber
offensichtlich wird er nicht ausreichend
verstanden auch in den eigenen reihen
das sehe ich anders glaube die meisten
deutschen verstehen sehr wohl nach
welchen prinzipien der kanzler handelt
sie verstehen aber auch dass in zeiten
des krieges es kein drehbuch gibt dass
man abarbeiten kann das steht auch in
keinem koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
sondern das ist ein tägliches tasten
nach grundsätzen nachdem wir unsere
politik ausrichten und ja sie haben es
einzelne stimmen genannt aber die muss
man ja auch entgegenhalten wie das dann
aus den eigenen reihen kommentiert wird
ich habe ein deutliches statement aus
der fdp am ende dieser sitzungswoche
vernommen was mir zufriedenheit angeht
mit dem auftritt des bundeskanzlers im
verteidigungsausschuss sein wunsch der
ausschussvorsitzenden frau
strack-zimmermann gewesen dem der
kanzler dort auch nachgekommen ist das
ist keine selbstverständlichkeit dass
dort regelmäßig dann auch bericht
erstattet wird und zu mancher aussage
von herrn hofreiter habe ich auch herr
nouripour aus den reihen der grünen
gehört dass das nicht in jedem fall
immer der gemeinsamen auffassung der
grünen partei entsprochen hat und auch
aus den reihen meiner partei gibt es hin
und wieder meine äußerung die jetzt
nicht mit der parteispitze vorher oder
dem generalsekretär abgestimmt wurde das
ist so damit müssen wir alle leben das
sagt aber erstmal noch nichts über die
ampel aus also das heißt ja eigentlich
in der interpretation
regel regelwerk des krisenzeiten kanzler
zeiten regierungszeiten sind das
spiegelt sich ja nicht wirklich in den
umfragen wieder was läuft hinter schief
also ich glaube das krisen-management
vom ende einer krise her bewertet wird
und wenn wir uns über den krieg in der
ukraine unterhalten dann muss man ja
leider festhalten dass das ende dieses
krieges bedauerlicherweise noch lange
nicht in sicht ist sondern wir sind
jetzt im dritten monat dieses krieges es
ist leider auch noch nicht in sicht dass
wir jetzt zeitnah bei
friedensverhandlungen angekommen wären
und dementsprechend spüre ich wenn ich
im land unterwegs bin und das waren wir
alle gerade in diesen wahlkämpfen ganz
viel vor allem viele menschen die sich
fragen stellen und die sagen wir
verstehen auch dass ihr uns jetzt hier
nicht ein ablaufplan darlegen könnte wie
das alles laufen wird aber wir wollen
dass ihr bedacht vorgeht ich aber dass
selten erlebt dass so viele menschen
aktiv an die info stände von parteien
kommen um ihre meinung zur aktuellen
ukraine politik dazu legen viele in
unserem fall die gekommen sind und
gesagt haben bitte auch bedacht bleiben
keine abenteuer machen keine alleingänge
machen und insofern glaube ich einfach
dass das zeiten sind in denen die
menschen gerade nicht morgens als erstes
mit der frage aufstehen wen würde ich
wählen wenn am nächsten sonntag
bundestagswahl wäre sondern die stellen
sich die frage wie können wir frieden in
unserer gesellschaft waren und ihn dort
in europa wieder herstellen und bündig
wir heute nicht herrscht frau werbung
ist ja als erste ministerin nach kers
gefahren
saerbeck ist dauerpräsent sie haben da
zwei angesehene hauptdarsteller macht es
ihnen der kanzler angenehm leicht oder
ist das auch ein problem für die ampel
also an der werbung und robert habeck
sind in sehr guten dialog mit olaf
scholz und das funktioniert sehr gut in
der koalition und es ist nun mal so dass
wir einen krieg haben einen krieg der
natürlich außenpolitisch begleitet
werden muss weshalb man in der werbung
als unsere außenministerin da viel in
den medien ist gleichzeitig ist das
thema wirtschaft und wie wir weg von den
fossilen energien kommen mit unserem
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz natürlich bei robert habeck
angesiedelt sonst könnte alle team ob du
gut aber der kanzler kümmert sich gerade
darum dass wir auch international auch
in den im hintergrund da vor allen
dingen die richtigen wege ziehen es gibt
engen austausch im kabinett es gibt ganz
enge absprachen der kanzler steuert das
natürlich und ich glaube herr kümmert
hat es gerade schon gesagt und sie haben
es auch gesagt oder scholz ist ja jetzt
auch öfter auch nochmal öffentlich
präsent gewesen und ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass die regierung da zusammen
steht in diesen krisenzeiten können wir
es uns auch einfach nicht leisten da und
es macht auch gar keinen sinn wir müssen
da gemeinsam jetzt die antworten auf die
drängenden fragen dieser zeit schießerei
einer ihrer kollegen hat diese
gemeinsamkeit durchbrochen der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher
farbe hat
den verteidigungsausschuss verlassen hat
jetzt in als konsequenz dann auch
übermorgen sein rücktritt zumindest
angeboten er hatte er olaf scholz heftig
dafür kritisiert habe zu wenige
antworten geliefert war das aus ampel
sich das fehlverhalten eines kollegen
oder hat er recht mit seiner kritik er
hat nicht recht rx das war eine spontane
reaktion er selbst bedauert diese
entscheidung und wir haben uns als fdp
ja auch klar zu diesem fall geäußert er
selbst hat ja auch schlussfolgerungen
daraus angeboten schauen sie mal wir
hatten eine diskussion gehabt innerhalb
der koalition als es um das thema
schwere waffen ging wir haben da
selbstverständlich unterschiedliche
geschwindigkeiten gehabt wir haben ein
bundesparteitag als fdp gehabt wo wir
uns sehr klar zu diesem thema auch
geäußert haben und am ende des tages
entscheiden war ja auch die die
vorletzte sitzung des deutschen
bundestages wo wir im grunde genommen
als koalition auch gezeigt haben dass
wir handlungsfähig sind und dass wir in
der lage sind selbst mal so einem
komplexen thema
sehr gute ergebnisse zu erreichen die
größte opposition im deutschen bundestag
hat mit gemacht von daher ist diese
debatte an der stelle auch erledigt das
was danach erfolgt im
verteidigungsausschuss bedauere ich sehr
aber wie gesagt das ist das ist eine
einzel positionierung hat man in gut
einem monat wählt ihre partei ihre
bundesspitze und auch der ultra-rechte
blöcke hat sich ins spiel gebracht zum
ukraine krieg würde ich ihnen gerne ein
zitat vorlesen von björn röcke die raum
fremde macht die dort nichts zu suchen
hat das sind die usa sie haben den staat
erstmal unterwandert mit ihrer
asymmetrischen kriegsführung um ihn dann
ins westliche lager zu ziehen und das
haben die russen mitgekriegt und jetzt
haben sie sich gewehrt zitat ende
ist das eine position die für den
bundesvorstand qualifiziert ich kenne
das zitat jetzt nicht aber dass ein
schlüssel für die möglichen
friedensverhandlungen
zwischen ukraine und russland den usa
liegt ist unbestritten wenn ich
vergangene woche klaus von dohnanyi
recht verstanden habe den spd granden
ist da der eigentliche schlüssel und
wenn wir gehört haben dass die usa so
weit gehen russland zu drohen man werde
sich so militärisch einsetzen dass
russland hinterher so gar nichts mehr
irgendwie fähig ist dann ist das der
falsche weg das zitat kenne ich jetzt
nicht aber dass die usa würde sagen das
unterschreibe ich kenne dass die tat
nicht sie haben vorgelesen ich muss es
mir
dass es kritische stimmen das ist
kritische stimmen in richtung usa auch
geben muss ist unbestritten unter fast
allen fachleuten leute wie du narr die
gehe so weit zu sagen das ist der
eigentliche schlüssel aber unser
hauptproblem in der republik um gerade
auch in nordrhein westfalen sind ja
nicht nur die waffen in nur kleinen die
kriege rey in der letzten in der
vergangenen woche ganz stark und das ist
im wahlkampf untergegangen und auch
medial hat es eine schießerei von 100
klaren leuten gegeben auf offener straße
stellen sich vor der wehr ein rechter
dabei gewesen mit einer waffe auf der
offenen straße 100 leute haben sich
überfallen das war ich wirklich meine
frage entscheiden aber da sich auf eine
antwort so würden sie sich von diesem
zitat distanzieren ich zitiere davon gar
nicht ich muss mir das anschauen dieses
regal ist diese wir müssen uns da gar
nicht länger verraten diese auch usa
kritischen einlassungen hinblick auf den
frieden zwischen russland und ukraine
ist völlig fraglos aber wir müssen auch
die eigentlichen themen in nrw uns
angucken und das thema jahrhundert
klärung herbei und 30.000 schweren
schwert hat haben sie eben schon mal
gesagt herr steht deutlich kommende
woche wird ist in berlin einen kongress
geben wir bleiben jetzt ein thema
ukraine mit dem titel ohne nato leben
ideen für den frieden da sitzen auch
bekannte
personen ihrer partei auf dem podium in
der einladung heißt es für deutschland
war und ist die nato verhängnisvoll ist
das position ihrer partei nein ich will
das auch so deutlich sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht ich glaube diesen
diesen kongress auch im vorfeld gesehen
und ich kann ganz deutlich sagen das ist
nicht ausdrücklich nicht die position
unserer partei unser partei hat zum
thema ukraine krieg eine klare position
wir kritisieren und verurteilen den
angriff krieg putin so einfach ist das
und da gibt es auch überhaupt nichts
anderes dazu zu sagen was wiederum die
zweite frage so da will ich direkt bei
kevin kühnert anknüpfen ist die frage
wie können wir jetzt in dieser situation
verantwortungsvoll so vorgehen dass das
nicht zu einem dritten weltkrieg wird
und diese frage müssen wir uns alle
stellen und wer hier sofort den
masterplan hat ja soll aufstehen ich
finde schon dass wir genau in dieser
situation sind wo wir natürlich abwägen
müssen wie können wir den aggressor
russland aber auf dem
unterbringungsgesetz entschuldigung mit
welchem ganz kurz mit welchen
möglichkeiten das geht zb im öl embargo
zb mit sanktionen gegen putins schergen
und zum beispiel aber auch der stärkung
des völkerrechts und der menschenrechte
da haben wir im übrigen auch als westen
durchaus das eine oder andere
nachzuholen stichwort kosovo stichwort
türkei stichwort april so aber sie haben
dass ihr euch hier das
wunderding um dann auch das auf dem
podium ihrer partei das ist kein
kongress der linken ich will das so
deutlich sagen das ist kein kongress der
linken und deswegen habe ich da auch
überhaupt nichts damit zu tun und teile
die position die dort vertreten werden
sollte ich weiß ja nicht genau
jedenfalls vertrete ich die von ihnen
beschriebene position nicht und das ist
auch nicht positionen der partei darüber
ihr parteivorsitzender praktizierte in
fragen des ukraine kriegs ein beherztes
sowohl als auch
einerseits die ukraine unterstützen aber
nicht in einen krieg gezogen werden
energie in barkow da ist ja auch
zurückhaltend was unterscheidet das
eigentlich vom zaudern und zögern das
die union olaf scholz vorwirft eine
ganze menge denn wir sind in unserer
position ja auch sehr geschlossen und
haben auch eine große gemeinsamkeit in
den eigenen reihen das erkenne ich per
olaf scholz unter ampelkoalition in
keinster weise wir haben auch letzte
woche darüber gesprochen
hier wird die große solidarität
beschworen der ampelkoalition wir sehen
uns beim sondervermögen 100 milliarden
für die bundeswehr wir sehen es bei der
sitzung des verteidigungsausschusses die
ampel steht eigentlich nur noch auf
tönernen füßen ehrlich ist und dass es
da ganz ganz großer unterschied herr
kümmert nicht auf die füsse angesprochen
oder finnland hat heute die offizielle
nato bewerbung beschlossen die
schwedische regierung spart sich
ebenfalls heute für das beitrittsgesuch
ausgesprochen sollten beide länder
sofort in die nato aufgenommen werden
auch wenn das die nato ja sehr nahe an
russland bringt dafür gibt es klare
spielregeln wie solche aufnahmen im
rahmen der nato ab zu laufen haben und
nach diesen kriterien kann eine aufnahme
jetzt stattfinden das ja nicht vom
himmel gefallen sondern es ist ja eine
entwicklung seit ausbruch des krieges in
seiner heutigen form dass es dort auch
demoskopisch erkennbar eine eine
politische entwicklung in den
gesellschaften finnlands und schwedens
gegeben hat da gab es langjährige
ablehnungen eines nato beitritts die
sich in anbetracht dessen was putin der
ukraine macht verändert haben und wer
wollte diesen gesellschaften mit ihren
sorgen die sie sich auch in diesem
moment machen jetzt das recht absprechen
teil einer gemeinsamen
schutzgemeinschaft zu werden bleibt mir
noch mal eben bei der innenpolitiker
shire
mit schwarz gelb ist ja in nordrhein
westfalen eine der klassischen
kombination
heute abgewählt worden das heißt denn
das für die ausrichtung ihrer partei ist
die fdp eigentlich überhaupt noch ihr
erster ansprechpartner oder müssen sie
sich neu orientieren
es ist angesprochen wurde wir haben ein
breites parteienspektrum und die aufgabe
besteht darin zunächst für seine eigenen
klaren positionen zu werben das haben
wir getan für eine starke wirtschaft für
eine gute innere sicherheitspolitik auch
für eine anständige bildungspolitik da
war auch bevor die cdu mit der fdp in
verantwortung kamen in nordrhein
westfalen einiges im argen und ich weiß
dass auch heute noch mit der
bildungspolitik nicht alle zufrieden
sind in nordrhein-westfalen deswegen
haben wir auch programmatisch stark
nachgearbeitet und die aufgabe besteht
darin jetzt eine verlässliche koalition
zu beenden die zukunfts koalition für
das land zu binden und wir haben gerade
eine reihe an internationalen krisen an
die wichtigste internationale krise
angesprochen nämlich diesen krieg das
ist aber nicht die einzige
internationale krise und aus dieser
krise gibt es auch in politische
schlussfolgerungen eine der
schlussfolgerungen ist daraus ist unsere
wirtschaft umzubauen das thema ökonomie
und ökologie zu damit zu denken und das
ist die aufgabe die man dann hat in
einer solchen koalition und in solchen
gesprächen zukunfts koalition zu bilden
zurück zur heutigen wahl das ist ein
klarer auftrag dies für hendrik wüst
auch zu tun und das wird jetzt die
schlussfolgerung für
nordrhein-westfalens herr über ihre
partei hat sich ja an bundes präsenz ja
deutlich eingebüßt ist das jetzt bis zur
landtagswahl das was man erwarten kann
also dass die das märz die bundespolitik
macht und die csu beschäftigt sich eher
mit den wahlaussichten wir beschäftigen
uns nicht mit den wahlabsichten wir
beschäftigen uns mit bayern das ist auch
unser auftrag den wir im landtag und in
der versicherung haben dass wir für
bayern arbeiten und das machen wir
voller überzeugung und auch so gut wie
uns natürlich auch damit beschäftigen
können und wollen und bayern steht gut
da und das ist nicht ganz zu trennen von
der arbeit der cdu nicht das mal so
sagen darf aber weniger präsenz im bund
wir sind natürlich auch im bund präsent
wir arbeiten auch eng zusammen mit der
cdu und die csu hat immer auch einen
bundespolitischen anspruch aber wir sind
da jetzt in der opposition und deswegen
gilt es hier auch konstruktive
oppositionsarbeit zu machen und vor
allem natürlich da wo wir in der antwort
in der verantwortung sind in bayern auch
für die menschen zu arbeiten
frau b schlussfrage an sie gemessen an
den eigenen ansprüchen sind sie
zufrieden mit dem auftreten und der
entscheidungsfreude in der ampel
wie ich eben schon gesagt habe ich
glaube in der ampel finden wir gute
lösungen aktuell wir arbeiten da
intensiv und gut zusammen über die drei
parteien hinweg das ist ja auch nicht
immer ganz einfach in der drei parteien
koalition aber ich finde es funktioniert
gerade sehr gut wir sehen dass annalena
baerbock robert habeck zusammen mit olaf
scholz und christian lindner da diese
diese koalition voran bringen und ich
glaube wird sehen auch gerade dass wir
in dem koalitionsvertrag auch die basis
dafür gelegt haben antworten für die
zukunft unseres landes zu geben wir
stellen gerade auch deutschland wir
reagieren auf das was der krieg gerade
von uns fordert wir reagieren mit einer
neuen noch nach vorne gewandten
energiepolitik und mit einer
außenpolitik die sich auch nach vorne
wendet die zum beispiel auch für
russische außenpolitik macht die aber
eben auch darüber hinaus deutschland in
der welt auch gerade stärkt deutschland
hat gerade eine stärkere position in
europa und das ist der ampelkoalition zu
verdanken herzlichen dank das war die
berliner runde zur landtagswahl in
nordrhein-westfalen und damit geben wir
schnell zurück ins wahlstudio uns wird
jeder chance ja danke schön theo koll
vielen dank für eine spannende berliner
runde und ja wir wollen die minuten bis
zum abendprogramm 2015 noch schnell mal
nutzen um sie jetzt auch in den
hochrechnungen auf den letzten stand zu
bringen und damit beginnen wir jetzt
auch frische zahlen so ist das bettina
die hochrechnung um 20.09 sieht die cdu
bei 35,5 prozent unten sehen sie die
gewinne und verluste spd käme demnach
auf 26,9 prozent mit verlusten die fdp
5,6 mit starken verlusten die afg 5,7
beide aber wahrscheinlich im parlament
die grünen mit sehr deutlichen
zugewinnen wie wir hier sehen und 18,2
prozent und die linke 2,1 prozent wieder
nicht im landtag vertreten jetzt schauen
wir mal auf die sitzverteilung
199 sitze waren es bisher es kann sein
dass es im laufe des abends noch
deutlich mehr werden über überhang und
ausgleichsmandaten und die cdu käme
jetzt bei 199 sitzen auf 77 die spd auf
58 fdp 12 afg 12 und die grünen 40 sitze
was heißt das für das regieren in
nordrhein-westfalen was ist möglich die
senkrechte linie bezeichnet die absolute
mehr die muss man erreichen oder
überschreiten 100 sitze braucht man dazu
die bisher regierende cdu fdp regierung
kommt nur auf 89 ist also definitiv
abgewählt schwarz-grün überschreitet die
linie deutlich mit 117 sitzen das ginge
also rot grün landet bei 98 2 sitze zu
wenig und spd/grüne mit fdp 110 auch das
würde deutlich reichen
ja danke schön matthias also der
wahlabend nähert sich mal dem ende es
ist zeit eine erste bilanz zu ziehen
wenn auch klar ist noch ist nicht
wirklich klar wer nrw am ende regieren
wird aber professor partys ein paar
hinweise glaube ich hat es heute abend
schon gegeben die cdu genommen
zusammenfassen vielleicht hat einen
wirklichen erfolg eingefahren die spd
ist enttäuscht aber noch nicht ganz
geschlagen die grünen sind die großen
gewinner die fdp mit herber niederlage
und die afg verliert weiter dass
vielleicht mal die kurzzusammenfassung
trauen sie sich schon zuzusagen wer in
nrw nach regieren wird das ist ein swing
state wieder wir haben einen regierungs
ministerpräsident der durchaus im amt
bleiben wird vermutlich aber mit einem
neuen partner sofern hat sich wieder
etwas verändert keine konstanz was
dieses land auch markant gemacht hat
schwarz-gelb hier abgewählte und die
grünen haben jetzt also gewinner die
qual der wahl ob sie mit der cdu gehen
oder vielleicht auch angeregt durch die
durch die bundesweite aktion dann doch
zu einer ampel tendieren die grünen
profitieren extrem jetzt auch offenbar
in serie und sie haben extrem rücken
wird eben von der bundespolitische linie
die erklär macht des vize-kanzlers wirkt
sich hier offenbar auch auszumachen
viele themen der wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik sie übernommen hat wir und
damit auch ein neues kompetenzfeld
erobert man sagt immer das ist auch ein
test nrw wahl ist auch ein test für die
bundespolitik wie ist er ausgefallen aus
ihrer sicht ja es soll ein politisches
erdbeben ein donnerschlag dem wir erlebt
haben gegen die ampel wo die grünen
profitieren die eine turnieren
dramatisch so sieht's aus am ende
vielleicht noch ein satz zur afd die ein
weiteres mal verliert wenn wir mal
geschaut das ist die neunte mit der
bundestagswahl der die zehnte
wahlniederlage für die fdp
kann man das sagen das scheint so zu
sein dass die ungute unmut in der
bevölkerung da ist sich anders
artikuliert als unmut auf sorger
scheinen sie ausgedient zu haben wo
gesagt hatte ganz herzlichen dank für
die einschätzungen am heutigen abend ja
liebe zuschauer damit neigt sich so
langsam hier auf unsere wahlsendungen
dem ende zu ich habe noch ein paar
hinweise für sie das ist klar erfreut
ist immer eine gute adresse um sich
jederzeit auf dem neuesten stand zu
halten und dann haben wir natürlich um
21 uhr 45 wie gewohnt das heute journal
mit weiterer analyse mit marietta slomka
so und matthias wie ihr fahrzeug aber
auch noch vehement denn
das bleibt natürlich um sie dann mit der
letzten hochrechnung im heute-journal
auch ganz aktuell zu versorgen